Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 127. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße euch alle zu einer weiteren Ausgabe On the Road. Ich befinde mich immer noch im Raum Darmstadt, eine Region, in der es offensichtlich eine ganze Menge Themenfelder für CRE zu bearbeiten gibt. Ich bin ja hier schon zum wiederholten Male und wenn ich mir so meine Wunsch- und Kandidatenliste so angucke, dann wird es mich hier noch häufiger in die Region treiben. Heute bin ich genau genommen ein bisschen zwischen Darmstadt und Frankfurt und heute soll es um ein Thema gehen, was auch schon sehr lange auf meiner, sowohl meiner persönlichen Wunschliste steht, als auch immer wieder von vielen Hörern angefragt wurde. Ein Thema, was eine ganz besondere Bedeutung auch hat in der Computerwelt. So viel kann ich auf jeden Fall schon voraussagen oder vorwegnehmen vielmehr. Es geht um TeX oder sollte man vielleicht TeX sagen, wie auch immer. Das werden wir gleich alles erfahren, denn ich kann begrüßen hier als Gast bei Chaosradio Express, dem Joachim. Joachim Schrod, hallo.
Hallo Tim.
Ja, ich bin bei dir zu Gast. Super, dass es geklappt hat. Und ja, du bist mit diesem Thema vertraut.
Naja, wir haben damit angefangen in Deutschland mehr oder weniger.
Genau. Vielleicht steigen wir auch mal ein bisschen über dich ins Thema ein. Du bist ja nun auch so das, was man so einen alten Hasen nennen kann, jetzt weniger vom Lebensalter her, sondern was deinen Bezug zu Computern, Netzwerken und Datentechnik im Allgemeinen betrifft. Bist du auch selber Informatiker?
Ich bin so schön, wenn man es so schön sagt, Graubart und das wortwörtlich zu nehmen.
Graubart.
Unix Greybirds.
Ja genau, die Harry Guys.
Ja genau, und dazu gehöre ich nun auch. Ich bin 1981 mitbekommen mit den ganzen Geschoss. Wir haben in Darmstadt angefangen zu studieren. Und das war die Hölle. Man saß an Lochkarten-Stansern, man hatte irgendwie Stunden zu warten, bis irgendwas da war und die einzige Auswahl, die einzige Ausweg, den es gab, aus diesem höllischen Zeug heraus war, es sich an eine Hiwi-Stelle zu beorganisieren. Was ich dann auch möglichst schnell getan habe, um dann bei so einem Prof lokal was zu arbeiten. Und dieser Prof hat 82, auf einmal kam er mit so einem Tape an. Aus einer Reise aus den USA, so ein neues Programm drauf. Das hieß irgendwie TeX oder so oder TeX. Und dann haben wir dann die ersten Ergebnisse gesehen und ich war baff. Ich bin schon immer im Büchernah gewesen. Bücher ist etwas, was für mich, wenn ich sagen sollte, ich habe Hobbys, dann sind das eigentlich nur zwei Bücher und Wein. Das ist so das was. Und dann auf einmal zu sehen, hier gibt es eine Möglichkeit, das, was ich immer nur gesehen habe, selber machen zu können. Das hat mich wirklich angefallen, regelrecht. Und das hat mich jetzt seit 1982, die letzten 27 Jahre, in meinem Privatleben nach wie vor wirklich beschäftigt. Und da bin ich aktiv geblieben. Das war damals der Punkt, wo man wirklich auf Mainframes gearbeitet hat. Also nichts mit PCs oder irgendwelchen persönlichen Gemüden. Das gab es schlicht und einfach nicht. Es gab den Commodore-Repet und das war ein Ding. Man hatte den Mainframe vor sich und hat angefangen, auf dem Mainframe den Compiler umzuschreiben, um das TeX zum Laufen zu bringen. Also man hatte nicht ein Programm, dass man dann irgendwann mal einen Compiler erst mal für gemacht, um sein Programm laufen zu lassen.
Du sagtest ja auch so schön, da kam jemand mit einem Band an. Heute würde man wahrscheinlich sagen, da habe ich mir was runtergeladen. Runterladen war da noch nicht.
Runterladen, das kam, naja, es kam Mittelbar, kam das Thema Runterladen so Ende der 80er hoch. Da gab es Bitnet. Bitnet, das ist vor dem Internet noch gewesen. Das war ein großes Netzwerk von IBM Mainframes, wo man dann per E-Mail die Sachen schicken lassen konnte in kleinen Häppchen, die man anschließend auf seinem System zusammengezogen hat und dann da gemacht hat. So habe ich meine erste Knuth-Software bekommen. Von Richard Stallman, per E-Mail verschickt in so und so Häppchen dann zu uns, dass wir in der mitarbeiten konnten und so die ersten Sachen machen konnten. Da war ich dann in der Uni ebenfalls noch als IWI tätig. 1990 habe ich dann eine Mitarbeitestelle bekommen an der Uni zur Promotion, die zwar leider nicht geklappt hat ganz am Ende, aber hochendesandte fünf Jahre gewesen sind, eine spannende Arbeit machen durfte, mit vielen Leuten zusammenarbeiten durfte. Und das war dann auch die Zeit, wo das Internet bei uns begonnen hat. Ich glaube, wir hatten den Internetanschluss 92. Das war die 91 oder 92. Wir waren die dritte Uni in Deutschland. Nach Dortmund und Karlsruhe.
Die Pioniere.
Genau. Und ich arbeitete damals an einem Institut, das eben auch Netzwerke gemacht hat. Und das da mit verantwortlich war, die Planung mitzumachen. Wir haben bei uns im Institut eben die ersten E-Mail-Systeme aufgesetzt. Wir haben die ersten Systeme aufgesetzt. War deswegen auch in dem Thema Internet drin. Und das hat dann später auch dann meinen Beruf bestimmt. Also ich habe mit TeX in beruflichen... Vor einem halben Jahr hatte ich schon gesagt, überhaupt nichts zu tun. Und im letzten halben Jahr habe ich dann doch mal was mit zu tun gehabt. Aber das war ein Zufall, den als es mir angeboten hat. Ich ergriffen habe. Ich muss dazu sagen, ich bin selbstständig. Also wir haben mit meiner Partnerin gemeinsam eine Firma. Das ist eine kleine IT-Beratungsfirma. Und diese macht normalerweise eigentlich solche Dinge wie Projektleitungen. Und nun gab es eine Gelegenheit, auch mal TeX wirklich einzusetzen, was ich ergriffen habe, bevor wir wirklich mal Software gemacht haben auch. Das ist etwas, was wir aber dann jetzt hier, denke ich, nicht wirklich dann in das Thema mehr reinpasst.
Naja, aber gut, sagst du, TeX ist dein Hobby, oder ich vermute auch mal eine gewisse Leidenschaft, was ich immer wieder... Es gibt zwar so einige Themen im Computerbereich, wo es, naja, also alles hat so seine Fans und alles hat so seine Unterstützer, aber es gibt so einige wenige Dinge, die eben auch wirklich so diesen Anspruch des vollständigen Heiligen Grails, also wo es wirklich eine nahezu religiöse Freude gibt. Ich übertreibe jetzt bewusst, aber du wirst mir sicherlich zustimmen. Also die Leute, die sich in der TeX-Szene engagieren, wie das eben in manchen anderen Sachen auch ist, die strahlen einfach eine besondere Überzeugtheit ab.
Es gibt Fans.
Es gibt Fans. Und das ist halt auch so eine der Sachen, die ich ganz gerne mal hinterfragen will, worauf das basiert. Aber für die Leute, die jetzt einfach noch überhaupt keine Ahnung haben, worüber wir jetzt eigentlich reden, oder es schon immer mal genau wissen wollten, sollen natürlich jetzt auch erstmal dieses Band nochmal genauer anschauen, was du da bekommen hast. Also, was für ein Band war denn das eigentlich?
Das war wirklich so ein... Wir reden nur von diesen großen Tellern da. Genau, auf die dann irgendwo, wenn es hochkam, mal gerade ein Megabyte draufpasste oder so.
Und was war da drauf?
Und da war drauf ein Pascal-Programm. Das Programm dient dazu, Bücher zu machen. TeX ist etwas, womit man ein Buch machen kann, zuallererst einmal. Das heißt, ich gebe irgendwo, erfasse in einer Datei meinen Text, so etwas wie Microsoft Word, nur das hinter, dass was rauskommt, schöner aussieht. Das ist dann das Fan-Tum natürlich, wo wir, die wir in der TeX-Community aktiv sind, der Ansicht sind, dass selbst nach diesen vielen Jahren, ich meine, wir reden jetzt hier über einen Zeitraum, die erste TeX-Version ist 1978 entstanden, 1982 die Version entstanden, die wir heute noch benutzen. Und jetzt haben wir 2009 und 27 Jahre später gibt es immer noch das Programm, das die Standards gesetzt hat.
Also wir reden von demselben Source Code, der immer noch in Pascal geschrieben ist?
Jawoll, der ist auch immer noch in Pascal geschrieben, genau.
Und wird auch noch dran gearbeitet?
Der Source Code ist ziemlich abgeschlossen, weil das TeX ist ein System, das aus Schichten besteht. Die aktuellen Arbeiten sind in den Schichten außen. Zu dem Thema können wir vielleicht später nochmal kommen, wie es in den aktuellen Entwicklungen im Bereich TeX ist. Es geht erst mal darum zu sagen, was TeX macht. TeX ist etwas, womit ich ein Buch erzeugen kann, das erstmal ganz fantastisch aussieht. Der Schwerpunkt, oder wie viele Bücher, sind aus dem naturwissenschaftlichen, mathematischen Raum. Das liegt daran, dass TeX eine besondere Stärke hat, und das ist der Formelsatz. Etwas, was wir ansonsten in sehr wenigen anderen Systemen finden. Aber selbst wenn ich keine Formelsätze habe, wenn ich einfach nur ein Buch habe, in dem ich irgendwo eine Querverweise haben möchte, in dem ich eine Bibliografie haben möchte, ein Buch habe, in dem ich irgendwelche Inhaltsverzeichnisse einfach haben möchte, wo ich einen Index haben möchte, der funktioniert und nicht irgendwo in die falsche Richtung zeigt, auf der falsche Seitennummer enthält, dann ist das etwas, wo TeX einfach ein Programm, eine Anwendung der Wahl ist, weil sie genau diese Dinge tut. Tabellen. Tabellen, wenn ich mich hergehen möchte und mich nicht überärgern, dass meine Abbildungen mir irgendwo durch die Gegend rutschen und schräg oben in der Seite sind und ich keine Ahnung habe, wie ich sie wieder nach unten bringe oder bei der kleinsten Reformatierung sie wieder in der Gegend landen. Wenn meine Abbildungen in welche Unterschriften haben sollen, die auch wirklich funktionieren sollen und nicht irgendwo auf der zweiten Seite rumstehen, also auf der Seite nach rumstehen sollen, dann wird dieser ganze Ärger, der in vielen Office-Produkten, die wir ansonsten nutzen und die ich auch selber auch nutze, ist nicht so, dass ich jetzt nur TeX nutze. Ich nutze auch selber Open Office und Microsoft Office ebenfalls. Wo ich mich aber bei solchen Dingen dann aber ärgere und dann denke ich mir, ja, das wäre mir jetzt ein TeX nicht passiert. Dafür ist es aber wiederum so, wenn ich jetzt hergehe und einen, zwei Seitenbrief schreiben möchte, dann ist das Medium, dann ist das TeX als Tool mit Kanonen auf Spatzen geschossen. Dann ist es etwas, wo ich sagen sollte, ja, dann rufe ich irgendwie meinen Open Office auf und schreibe meine zwei Seiten hin. Oder wenn ich so eine Präsentation mache, ja, dann habe ich sehr häufig, dass ich dann mit Powerpoint arbeite, weil die mediale Gestaltung da ist. Und das liegt aus folgendem Grund. TeX hat das Prinzip zu sagen, wir kümmern uns mit dem Programm um das Layout. Und der Autor soll schon mit Inhalt kümmern. Der Autor sagt in seinem Dokument, das ist eine Überschrift, das ist die erste, zweite Überschrift, erste, zweite Ebene. Das hier ist eine Aufzählung, das ist eine Tabellenspalte. Und das System macht dazu das passende Layout. Das heißt, man geht nicht her und sagt, das Ding ist jetzt fett und ist irgendwo so und so groß und macht es noch größer und hat dann irgendwo etwas, wo ich sage, ich mache es größer oder so. Sondern ich wähle aus, was ist die Struktur meines Textes, meines Buches. Und diese Vorgehensweise, das ist ähnlich wie bei HTML. Wenn man mal eine Webseite sich angeschaut hat, wie das aussieht und nicht eine von den HTML-Seiten nimmt, die jetzt voll durchdesigned sind, sondern eine HTML-Seite nimmt, die relativ straight forward aussieht, dann hat man auch Elemente, die übrigens aus TeX herauskommen. Es ist kein Zufall, dass die so ähnlich sind in HTML. Das liegt daran, weil die HTML-Schaffer sind TeX-Anwender gewesen und haben einen guten Teil dieser Namen, die da benutzt werden, aus einer TeX-Variante herausgenommen, nämlich im sogenannten TeX-Info. Das ist das Dokumentationssystem der GNU-Leute. Und diese HTML-Struktur, so kann man es sich vorstellen, so ähnlich gibt man das in TeX ein. So eine Art Tag nennt man das, eine Auszeichnung. Das heißt, man hat einen Hinschreiber, hier beginnt nun meine Überschrift, dann kommt der Überschrift Text, dann endet meine Überschrift. Hier beginnt eine Aufzählung, dann kommt meine Aufzählung und dann endet meine Aufzählung. Und das schreibe ich in meine Datei hinein. Dafür gibt es dann zwei Methoden. Entweder man nimmt einen normalen Editor und tippt das wirklich ein. Oder man hat solche Autoren-Systeme, wo man dann auch etwas zum Anklicken hat. Wo man dann sagt, okay, ich wähle jetzt aus, dass ich jetzt hiermit eine Liste haben möchte. Und das ist sehr vergleichbar mit HTML-Editoren.
Ja, es ist die Alte Mär von Syntax und Semantik, die man da an der Stelle auseinanderhält. Die Syntax ist aber jetzt nicht wie HTML.
Nein.
Die spitzen Klammern, was ja, also sag ich auch wiederum aus S-GML, das ist ja auch vor TeX oder zeitgleich.
Das ist ziemlich zeitgleich gewesen.
Aber auch S-GML hatte ja doch diesen Ursprung, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, auch im Satz ein bisschen. Also, sagen wir mal, im Erfassen von...
S-GML hat den Ursprung eigentlich mit der Goldfarbe gemacht zu einem Zeitpunkt, wo es bei IBM eine Sprache namens GML gab, General Markup Language. Und das hat IBM dazu benutzt, eine Manuale zu machen. Und dann hat Goldfarbe, um S-GML zu schaffen, das noch einmal verallgemeinert. Das war eine sehr spezielle Sprache und dazu benutzt, um wirklich in die Dokumente mehr Meta-Informationen reinzubringen, mehr Information und Struktur reinzubringen, damit man die besser verwalten kann, damit man sie für Übersetzungen besser benutzen kann usw. Und das war der Anfang vom S-GML. S-GML ging aus dem erzeugten Manual. Genau. Wir gingen weg von dem, wohingegen TeX hat eine ganz andere Geschichte. TeX ist der Punkt, dass Donald Knuth, der Schöpfer von TeX, ist einer der bekanntesten oder berühmtesten Informatiker. Er hat ein Standardwerk geschrieben, The Art of Computer Programming. Das ist für viele Informatiker so eines der Werke, die man als Informatiker da hat. Die wenigsten haben es wirklich gelesen, muss man dazusagen. Das ist eins von diesen Büchern, die man kauft ins Regal stellt und niemand liest sie hinterher. Ja klar, hinter dir steht einer. Semi-Numerical Algorithms.
Bin ich gerade in die richtige Reihe?
Ja genau, und zwar da ganz links musst du rüber schauen, das zweite Buch auf der linken Seite. Und da ist auch der Knuth. Und wenn man das war, gesetzt, eins daneben. Nein, noch eins. Das sind nach links, nach links. Und diese Bücher, die waren klassisch in Plei gesetzt, mit einem sehr hohen Anspruch. Knuth ist jemand, der Bücher wirklich auch den Anspruch hat, nicht nur inhaltlich exzellent zu sein, sondern eben auch das Aussehen wirklich gut zu haben. Knuth ist jemand, der, wenn ein Absatzumbruch nicht gut ist, wenn er nicht etwa hergeht und irgendwelche Trennhilfen reinmacht, nein, er macht eine Formulierung neu, um den Umbruch besser aussehen zu können. Also ich habe mit ihm gesprochen und er hat mir erzählt, dass er zum Teil irgendwo Absätze eingefügt hat oder weggeladen oder gekürzt hat, damit der Seitenumbruch besser wird. Also dieser Mann ist fanatisch. Dieser Mann ist in dem Punkt, der will eine Einheit schaffen, eine Einheit von Inhalt und Form. Fast ein barockes. Das ist so das, was man aus dem barocken kennt, dass Leute diese Form und Inhalt auf eine ähnliche Ebene stellen und sagen, das Beide hat es auseinander zu tun.
Ja, das kann ich sehr gut nachvollziehen.
Und das ist etwas, was Knuth gemacht hat. Und der Verlag, bei dem das veröffentlicht wurde, Edison Wesley, war nicht in der Lage, ihm die Qualität des Satzes, so wie er es haben wollte, zu machen. Woraufhin, er hat sowieso gerade einen Forschungssemester vor.
Also woran hat es da gemacht?
Also Kosten.
Hast du das gerne in toll gehabt und haben gesagt, da ist ja viel zu teuer.
Genau.
Also wäre schon irgendwie gegangen, aber wäre ein hoher manueller Aufwand gewesen.
Man muss sehen, gerade wenn das hier ein Buch ist, das auch sehr viel mit Formeln enthält, da eben kommt auch dann die Stärke her, die TeX, eine der Stärken für einen technischen Formelsatz auszeichnet. Und diese, wenn man sich ansaut, wie mit Plei gesetzt wird, bedeutet das, dass ein normaler Pleisatz, hat man so einen Winkelkasten, da werden die Pleitypen klassisch per Hand reingelegt. Oder hier, das ist dann mit einer 1,5 gesetzt, da hat man dann wieder eine Art Schreibmaschine. Dann fallen die Typen in so einen Winkelkasten-ähnlichen Lage hinein. Dann werden dann mit der Schreibmaschine solche Watt-Zwischenräume eingesetzt. Die drücken das Ganze auseinander. Das ist, kann man sich voll wie so ein Feder vorstellen, die diese Pleitypen auseinander macht. Und anschließend kann man damit normale Bücher ganz gut machen. Das geht verhältnismäßig schnell. Wenn man einen Mathematik-Satz hat, muss man wieder per Handsatz arbeiten. Dann muss wieder der Handsetzer her, der den Winkelkasten nimmt und zum Teil die Feile nimmt, um an Typen was abzufeilen, um da zum Beispiel so ein Exponent irgendwo oben dran zu setzen. Wenn man also a hoch b hat, wird die a-Type genommen, die Feile angesetzt, da oben das am Rand der Ecke abgefeilt, um da so ein kleines b hinsetzen zu können.
Also wenn man jetzt so das Buch hier durchblättert, dann merkt man sofort, dass das natürlich da schnell an die Grenzen stößt, weil das ist einfach voll mit Formeln und zwar nicht nur so die Formeln, die man so häufig antrifft, sondern auch so die, die man eigentlich am liebsten nie sehen will, weil sie irgendwie schon nahezu geometrische Erscheinungsbilder haben. Zum Thema Linotype und wie die funktioniert haben, habe ich übrigens auch schon hier einen ganz interessanten und empfehlenswerten Podcast, deswegen werfe ich ihn auch nochmal kurz ein. Ausgabe Nummer 80, Geschichte der Typografie ist die ganze Geschichte von Gutenberg bis Linotype bis hin zu den Fonds. Wer das noch nicht gehört hat, möchte an dieser Stelle vielleicht mal kurz auf Pause drücken, um das besser nachvollziehen zu können.
Den hätte ich mir anhören sollen als Vorbereitung. Das habe ich nicht gesehen, den höre ich mir auch nochmal an. Jawohl. Aber um weiterzukommen, der Knuth hatte damals so einen Forschungssemester und dann meinte er, ach, das ist ja kein Problem, dann schreiben wir mal ein Programm dafür. Und das ist The Famous Last Words oder so, da schreiben wir mal ein Programm dafür. Also nix einfacher als das, ja. Zehn Jahre später oder so, dann war das Programm dann auch wirklich abgeschlossen für ihn. Er hat seit der Zeit kaum noch etwas an dem System gearbeitet.
Zehn Jahre später, also er hat was 68 angemacht.
Nein, nein, das war die erste Ausgabe, hat er irgendwie schnell gemacht. Es gibt von ihm auch eine Geschichte, also ein aufgeschriebenes Tagebuch, wie schnell es da war. Die ersten Versionen des Programms waren innerhalb von, ich glaube, drei Monaten oder so vorhanden, aber das eigentliche TeX-Projekt in Stanford, unter seiner Leitung, war es ca. zehn Jahre, so weit ich mich erinnere, aktiv und danach hat er endgültig gesagt, er macht nichts mehr. In den letzten Jahren hat er aber auch selber angefangen, sich stark zurückzuziehen. Ich denke, Knuth hat intensiv gearbeitet, von 78 bis ungefähr 82 oder 83 an dem System, also ungefähr fünf Jahre, und danach wurde es immer weniger. Und momentan kümmert er sich nur noch alle paar Jahre mal darum.
Es gibt nicht so viele Software, in denen nur fünf Jahre gearbeitet wurde und die danach 27 Jahre später noch zum Einsatz kommt.
Ja und, ehrlich gesagt, fällt mir überhaupt nichts ein. Das ist das Besondere. Ich meine, wir reden ja hier auch über eine Open-Source-Anwendung, also was man heutzutage Open-Source nennt, auch wenn sie diesen Begriff 1982, wo ich damit in Kontakt kam, noch gar nicht gab. Damals gab es mit Mute und Note den Begriff freier Software, den Stallman damals gerade hochbrachte. Das ist ja auch ungefähr die Zeit gewesen, wo die Knubi begonnen hat. Und das war aber eine Self-Renotigkeit, dass man den Source hatte, dass man da selber Hand angelegt hat, dass man auch selber Programme geschrieben hat, um dann eben auch, wie gesagt, hier Bücher machen zu können. Diese Faszination, selber ein Buch gesetzt zu sehen und zu selber machen zu können, das war das Besondere.
Was mich jetzt fragt, ich meine, das war jetzt 68. 68 war...
78 hat er damit begonnen, nicht 68.
Ja, aber die erste Ausgabe ging doch 68 los.
Von TeX.
Ne, von seinen Büchern.
Von den Büchern.
Also von dieser Art of Computer Programming.
Das weiß ich nicht, wann die erste aufgerufen wird.
Also du sagst, die I-Wissen im Müllhalde.
Ah ja, okay, gut.
Ich weiß ja jetzt nicht, ob er von Anfang an schon TeX dort zum Einsatz gebracht hat.
Nein, nein, die erste Auflage ist mit Play gesetzt und es ging um die Schaffung der zweiten Auflage. Die sollte 1978 herauskommen und da hat er dann das System und nicht nur TeX alleine, sondern er hat auch gleich einen Zeichensatz damit gemacht. Da hat er mit Zapf, der den meisten Zuhörern vielleicht aus dem Windows-Menü als Schöpfer des Zapf-Ding-Buds oder so bekannt ist, einer der profilierendsten Typografen unserer Zeit, zusammengearbeitet, der übrigens in Darmstadt wohnt.
Ach wirklich?
Ja, der also auch... Ja, der lebt noch und ein total fitter Mann ist. Also der ist wirklich fantastisch. Der auch regelmäßig auf unseren Veranstaltungen, die wir von der User-Community der TeX machen, vorbeischaut und da auch gerne ein Ganges in der Gaste ist. Und der ist fasziniert, dass, wie er immer so schön sagt, junge Leute gefällt an Typografiehafen. Das ist etwas, was ihn fasziniert. Und der hat Knuth beraten über die Entwicklung von Schriften. Da wurden zwei Schriftfamilien in der Zeit erzeugt, Computer Modern und die Euler-Schriftfamilie, die in diese beiden Dinge Schriften zu machen und Bücher zu setzen. Das ist das, was Knuth in diesem Umfeld des TeX eben hinterlassen hat. Und ansonsten ist er ein Theoretiker. Ansonsten hat er mit Software eigentlich wenig zu tun. Das ist nicht jemand, der ansonsten irgendwas mit Software Engineering oder sonst irgendwas zu tun hat, sondern das ist jemand, der die Theorie der Informatik ja mitbegründet hat. Also er ist im Bereich formale Sprachen einer derjenigen, der überhaupt das Gebiet mit seinen attributierten Grammatiken nach vorne getrieben hat. Er ist theoretischer Informatiker, ist von Haus aus Mathematiker. Und da hat er so einen Ausflug, in das wir machen mal was Konkretes Praktisches gemacht. Und wie alle die Zeit und Aufwand der Programmierung unterschätzt, aber dafür hat er auch was rausbekommen, das eben wirklich gut ist. Und mit dem Perfektionismus, mit dem er arbeitet. Knuth ist Perfektionist ohne Ende. Er bezahlt für Fehler in Büchern und in Software. Das heißt, wenn man in seinem Buch einen Tippfehler findet, wenn man in seinen Büchern irgendwo etwas findet, wo auch einfach nur ein Verweis falsch ist, bekommt man Geld von Knuth.
Oder ein Komma?
Oder ein Komma falsch ist, jawohl, genau. Das heißt, er schreibt Shacks aus dazu. Es gibt also Shacks von Knuth, wo man dann irgendwo... Ein Shack von der Wells Fargo Bank. Ich müsste auch noch einen da haben. Ich habe natürlich nicht eingelöst. Und viele von uns...
Das macht, glaube ich, keiner, wenn ich das richtig mitbekommen habe, oder?
Oh doch, ich kenne Leute, die haben so viele Shacks bekommen, dass sie auch welche eingelöst haben. Und das ist irgendwann... Die haben dann so den ersten oder so aufgehangen und hat jetzt auch...
In Bezug auf die Bücher oder in Bezug auf seine Software?
Auf beides. Und...
Was für Summen hat er dann so herausgegeben?
Ja gut, das ist dann... Auch da ist so eine Runde Summen, ja. Zuerst beginnt das irgendwie mit zwei Dollar 56, dann fünf Dollar zwölf und das wurde dann jedes Jahr verdoppelt. Und da gibt es schon auch Shacks, die in die hunderten von Dollar reingehen. Und ich glaube, ich weiß nicht wie momentan, gerade bei Art of Computer Programming, der Kurs, wenn man das so nennen dürfte, ist aber sowohl bei seinen Büchern, Art of Computer Programming, als auch bei den Tech-Büchern, die er geschrieben hat, als auch bei der Tech-Software, gilt, wer einen Fehler bekommt, findet, bekommt dafür Geld.
Und zwar immer doppelt so viel wie derjenige, der den Fehler davon gefunden hat?
Nein, es wurde so jährlich ungefähr verdoppelt, die Summe.
Ach so, also auch wenn kein Fehler gefunden wurde und wieder ein Jahr vergangen ist, würde man dann doppelt so viel bekommen?
Ja, und das war etwas, was er über viele Jahre gemacht hat. Wie gesagt, ich weiß momentan nicht, wie zurzeit irgendwo das Ganze...
Das könnte aber immer sehr teuer werden.
Das könnte sehr teuer werden. Momentan, zumindest was die TeX-Sachen betrifft, schaut er nur noch alle paar Jahre nach Fehlern. Es gibt da jemand in Amerika, die Barbara Beaton, die sammelt für ihn die Fehler, die Fehlermeldungen ein. Und alle paar Jahre kommt er mal wieder aus der Versenkung hervor und sagt, schau mal mal wieder an, welche Fehler gefunden sind. Das heißt, momentan hat er das Ganze ziemlich... Aber er ist ja mittlerweile auch ein älterer Herr geworden, der schon lange Zeit emeritiert schreibt. Ja, schreibt noch an seinen Büchern weiter. Er hat jetzt noch einen vierten Band irgendwo in der Mache. Es sollte man sieben Bände von diesem VR-Of-Computer-Programming ursprünglich geben. Und ich habe Knuth mehrfach getroffen, habe auch, muss ich sagen, für mich die Ehre. Und es ist wirklich für mich eine Ehre gewesen, dass er uns auch hier mal besucht hat, wo wir dann mit ihm auch unterwegs waren. Hat er eigentlich einen deutschen Ursprung? Seine Frau kommt hier aus der Gegend Schöll. Sogar die waren hier in Odenwald irgendwo auf Ahnen-Suche. Die Amerikaner haben ja häufig dieses Febel für, wo sind meine Ahnen her. Und die waren hier auch in Darmstadt im Archiv, um nachzuschauen, wie jetzt seine ursprüngliche Ahnen oder Vorgänge, das ist mir unbekannt. Aber was ich damals erstaunt war, war, einer der berühmtesten Informatiker, Computer-Scientists auf der ganzen Welt, ist gleichzeitig einer der bescheidensten Menschen, die ich jemals in meinem Leben kennengelernt habe. Das ist so, der nimmt sich so zurück, und der ist von sich selber überhaupt nicht überzeugt, obwohl er wirklich jemand ist, der einen Anlass dazu hätte, einen Anlass dazu hätte, arrogant zu sein, einen Anlass dazu hätte, zu sagen, ich bin derjenige, der hier alles kann, aber er ist derjenige, der das eben genau nicht tut, sondern der auch zuhört sehr intensiv. Ein ungeheuriger Zuhörer unter jemanden, der eine Arbeitsgeschwindigkeit, ein Arbeitspensum hat, das ist unwahrscheinlich. Da gibt es eine Anekdote, die ganz interessant ist. Leslie Lambert, auch der Schöpfer von LaTeX, dazu kommen wir vielleicht nachher noch, was LaTeX ist, ist auch ein ganz berühmter Informatiker, der im Bereich Verteile Systeme viel gearbeitet hat und von David Colportiert, dass er gemeinsam mit Knuth irgendwelche Papers geschrieben hat, also wissenschaftliche Artikel zur Veröffentlichung. Und er hätte sich dann beeilt und beeilt und ganz intensiv gearbeitet und wäre froh gewesen, mit Knuth gemeinsam das Paper zu schreiben. Und dann sind sie dann angekommen bei ihrem Sekretariat und haben mitbekommen, in der gleichen Zeit hat Knuth noch drei weitere Papers geschrieben. Und das ist das, was Knuth ausmacht. Und er hat kein Wort drüber verloren. Das ist das, was auch Knuth ausmacht. Ich weiß nicht, ob diese Story wahr ist. Sie wird kolportiert, wie gesagt. Also ich habe sie nicht von Leslie Lampert selber gehört, aber es ist etwas...
Es ist so schön, dass wir sie auf jeden Fall glauben.
Genau, so nehme ich das auch. Und weil ich eben auch erlebt habe, wie schneller man arbeiten kann und wie schnell er Dinge erzeugt, das ist unwahrscheinlich. Aber gut, ich schlappe zurück von einem Detour.
Ja, das ist ja auch alles sehr interessant. Und ich finde, das ist auch sehr wichtig, dass man das versteht, was hinter dieser Software steht. Weil häufig hat man ja nun bei Software eben nicht unbedingt den Eindruck, dass die Leute sich besonders viele Gedanken gemacht haben. Es gibt da ja auch verschiedene Kirchen, die sagen, das ist jetzt auch eine besondere Stärke. Da war halt irgendwann mal ein bisschen Schund. Weil so ein kleiner Hack, der irgendwie ein Problem gelöst hat und dann hat sich da drauf, was weiß ich, ein Betriebssystem, ein GUI-Tool, was auch immer, daraus entwickelt. Und dann ist es eben deswegen toll, weil es so organisch gewachsen ist. Und dann gibt es dann halt so auch so die katholische Kirche des Programmierens, wo halt wirklich einer sich hinsetzt und sagt, wir haben jetzt hier ein Problem und das muss jetzt immer gelöst werden. Und dann wird da so in so einem Zen-Modus irgendwann mal was gemacht. Und dann ist es dann auch gleich perfektionistisch.
Gut, das ist eben schon die zweite. Das ist schon eine Kathedrale, was wir hier haben. Also wir haben hier nicht den Bazaar. Wir haben hier nicht den Bazaar, dessen jeder programmiert hier mit oder so etwas. Das ist Knuths Programm alleine.
Da hat auch wirklich niemand noch irgendwie Hand angelegt?
Nein, da hat auch niemand Hand angelegt. Es ist auch so, dass wenn man, das ist punktendlich wie wenn man heutzutage Firefox oder so hat. Man darf den Source nehmen, darf ihn ändern und so weiter. Dann darf man es nicht mal TeX nennen. Das heißt, sobald man hergeht und diesen Source nimmt, man darf das TeX im Namen bestehen lassen. Aber es darf nicht mehr TeX sein. TeX ist ein Nutzprogramm. Es gibt einen Trademark dafür, auch wirklich. Und das bleibt das Nutzprogramm. Und wenn dann irgendjemand hergeht, das OriginalteX, damals gab es solche Dinge wie PostScript und PDF noch nicht. Es hat was ausgegeben, das nennt sich DVI. Das ist so eine Zwischenform, möglichst kompakt. Und die wurden dann mit so einen Druckertreibern entweder auf dem Bildschirm angezeigt, also im Preview auf dem Bildschirm angezeigt, damit man sieht, was man überhaupt hat. Wir reden ja hier von einer Zeit, wo wir auch häufig noch keine Mauser hatten. Wir reden von einer Zeit, wo man typischerweise sehr viel nur wirklich etwas eingeben konnte an einem Terminal und dann eben, wenn man Glück hatte, ein grafisches Terminal dabei hatte. Oder man kann es ausdrucken auf einem Laserdrucker, auf einem Nadeldrucker. Wir reden ja auch hier über 82. Mein allererstes Buch, das wir hier gemacht haben, haben wir von einem 120 dpi Nadeldrucker doppelt so groß ausgegeben und dann runterkopiert, um hinterher 240 dpi zu bekommen.
Als jetzt die Art of Computer Programming, also als TeX dann sozusagen so weit war, dass er dann sein Buch damit auch veröffentlichen konnte, welche Technik wurde denn dann verwendet, um quasi aus diesem in TeX geschriebenen Buch den Satz zu machen? Kamen da jetzt schon so Belichtertechniken zum Einsatz?
Das ist Belichter. Nur Zugriff auf Belichter war für uns an der Uni nicht verhältlich. Also das Buch wurde mit einem Belichter gemacht. Das heißt, es gab sehr früh auch Druckertreiber für Belichter, die eben dieses DVI-Format in einen Belichter-Kommandostrom, das das Ding belichtet, umgesetzt hat. Irgendwann später gab es dann DVI- noch Postscript, auch mit PDF-Ausgabe. Und wir, die wir das mit den begrenzten Mitteln an der Universität, wo es keine Belichter gab, gemacht haben, wir haben das Ganze ausgegeben, die ersten Dinge, wie gesagt, auf Nadel-Drucker und später Laser-Drucker. Und das ist auch heute noch, ich denke, der Laser-Drucker ist heutzutage das Hauptausgabemedium, das man bei dem Druck hat. Und natürlich in dem Augenblick, wenn man PDF erzeugt und es zur Druckerei gibt, dass die dann die großen Belichter damit ansteuern.
Publishing ist ja überhaupt eine der Hauptanwendungen für Computer gewesen in 80er Jahren. Also es war ja im Desktop-Bereich die Revolution, eben das Desktop- Publishing, Apple mit seinem Macintosh und mit dem Laser-Freiter, die Kombination hat ja einiges in Bewegung gebracht. Das hier ist jetzt quasi auch Desktop-Publishing, bloß eben nicht auf dem Desktop, sondern im großen Rechnerraum, da wo halt die Belichter herumstanden. Jetzt würde ich ganz gerne nochmal versuchen zu erarbeiten, wie denkt TeX? Also was ist sozusagen die Abstraktion, die Knuth jetzt sich herbeiprogrammiert hat, in der man setzt? Also du hast ja schon angedeutet, ich schreibe alles in Text, ich benutze eine Auszeichnungssprache, eben TeX, die hat Ähnlichkeiten konzeptionell, eben mit solchen Sachen, wie man sie heute kennt, mit HTML, das heißt ich definiere eine Semantik in meinen Text, ich sage, das hier ist ein... und indem ich das einfach in das Textdokument schreibe, übergebe ich das diesem TeX-Prozessor.
Ja, das ist aber nicht Knuthswerk. Da muss man vielleicht, da möchte ich doch ein ganz kleines bisschen ausholen. Wir haben drei Teile, wenn man so möchte. Eine Basis, das ist die von Knuth, und heutzutage zwei Teile auf dem knutschen Basis obendrauf, und das eine nennt sich LaTeX, und das andere nennt sich Context. Die stehen nebeneinander. Die haben unterschiedliche Prinzipien, unterschiedliche Philosophien.
Aber die gab es doch noch nicht schon, als er sein Buch gesetzt hat.
Nein, der hat das mit seinem Original gemacht. Also nur mit TeX.
Also das heißt, man braucht die anderen Komponenten aber eigentlich auch nicht wirklich.
Man braucht die nicht wirklich, aber ich würde niemandem empfehlen, das mit dem so zu machen, wie Knuth es gemacht hat.
Ja gut, aber mich würde das jetzt erstmal interessieren, wie Knuth es gemacht hat.
Ja, Knuth hat ein System gemacht, wo man der Satz passiert mit, muss ich mal sagen, was meinst du wissen, wie er arbeitet oder wie das System funktioniert?
Er hat sich ja sein TeX jetzt programmiert und wollte sein Buch rausbringen. Es muss ja dann irgendwie was kommen, was dann die Buchfirma sozusagen auf ihren Belichter schmeißen kann. Das heißt, er hat sein Buch geschrieben in TeX.
Ja, genau. Und dieses TeX-System enthält eine Makrosprache. Mit der Makrosprache wird das dann auf Primitive umgesetzt. Also eine Makrosprache bedeutet das Ding...
Hat die auch noch mal einen eigenen Namen, diese Makrosprache?
Nein, nein, die heißt die TeX-Makrosprache. Das ist so... Wie nennen Sie Plain-TeX heutzutage? Um sie abzugrenzen gegenüber den LaTeX und anderen Sachen. Das Plain-TeX ist dann diese Makrosprache, wird umgesetzt in die Basisfähigkeiten, die TeX hat. Die Basisfähigkeiten, die TeX hat, bedeutet, dass es irgendeine Wörter aneinanderreit, einen Absatz baut, den Absatz umbricht, dabei eine Trennung macht und anschließend die Absätze oder die Zahlen, die dabei gewonnen wurden, zu Seiten zusammensetzt und dabei die Seiten macht und dabei sich Dinge auch noch merkt, die man braucht, um später noch ein Inhaltsverzeichnis machen zu können, um später irgendwelche Kopfzeilen, so einen lebenden Kolumnentitel, das ist, wenn eine Kopfzeile oben drüber steht, in welchem Kapitel wir gerade sind und dies wird aufgehoben während des Satzes, damit man weiß, wo ist man gerade und das kann wieder benutzt werden, abgefragt werden.
Und das ist eine volle Programmierstrache. Ja, und es gibt vor allem, also es gibt Papier, sozusagen, also es hat eine Vorstellung von einer Seite, die hat Render und so weiter und die folgen aufeinander und es gibt eine Seitennummer und es gibt dann vielleicht auch ein links und ein rechts.
Und diese, das ist die Basisfähigkeit von TeX eigentlich. Die Basisfähigkeit von TeX ist es, zu wissen, was ist ein Zeichen, das weiß man, wie es aussieht übrigens, das weiß man nur, wie groß ein Zeichen ist. Weil um ein Zeichen als Setzer zu setzen zu können, muss man nicht wissen, wie es aussieht. Das Aussehen ist in dem Moment weitgehend unwichtig.
Aber es gibt auch so etwas wie Ligaturen, wo dann die da zusammenfließen.
Ja, das sind dann ein neues Zeichen. Wenn ich ein F und ein I habe zum Beispiel und die beiden rutschen zusammen und das F-Burge nimmt den Platz des I-Punkts ein, dann ist das ein neues Zeichen, das ist das FI-Zeichen. Und das ist ebenfalls etwas, was in TeX vollautomatisch gemacht wird, wo in dem Augenblick, wo TeX ein F und ein I sieht oder ein F und ein F sieht, diese zwei einktippten Buchstaben durch ein angezeigtes Zeichen, nämlich das I für I-Zeichen, ersetzt und dann ausgibt. Und diese Informationen, welche Ligaturen es gibt, die stehen in den Fonds, in den Zeichensätzen. Die werden von da herausgenommen. Oder es gibt auch Informationen, zum Beispiel, wenn man zwei Buchstaben aufeinander folgt, müssen die mehr zusammenrutschen oder weiter weggehen. Etwas, was man im Englischen kerning nennt. Im Deutschen nennt man es Ausgleich und Spazierung. Und das ist auch etwas, was TeX einfach aus den Informationen, aus den Zeichensätzen herausnimmt. Und damit dann zuerst den Absatzumbruch macht und dann den Seilumbruch macht. Das heißt, in TeX haben wir, wenn man so möchte, mehrere Komponenten. Wir haben die Idee, was ist ein Zeichensatz mit den Informationen drin. Wir haben die Möglichkeit, dass man Absätze und Seitenumbruch machen kann. Wir haben eine Spezialkomponente, die Formelsatz macht. Formelsatz ist da so etwas anderes, weil der hat so eine gewisse Art von Zweitdimensionalität. Weil man macht Dinge übereinander und schräg nebeneinander und man hat irgendetwas, wo was hingesetzt wird, wo was schräg oben, schräg unten, links und rechts davor kommt, wo die Abstände speziell sein müssen, Wurzelzeichen, Dicke Klammern, die sich anpassen müssen, automatisch dem Größe, was dazwischen ist, das heißt, wenn ich ne Klammer aufmache und dahinter etwas, dann soll der Anwender, der Autor, nicht selber die Größe der Klammer aussuchen müssen. Das soll das System für ihn machen. Der soll hinschreiben, ich hab nen Bruch mit dem Zähler und dem Nenner und dann hab ich ne Klammer drumrum und dann wird die Klammergröße oder auch die Größe Summenzeichen davor oder des Integralzeichens voll automatisch.
War denn TeX dann auch das erste System, was überhaupt mit Vektorfonds gearbeitet hat? Weil all diese ganzen Fähigkeiten fordern ja dann auch eine Beschreibung in Vektoren, dass wirklich Linien gemalt werden, diese Fonds.
TeX selber hat mit der Idee, welche Fonds es gibt nicht und ganz am Anfang hat TeX auch nicht mit Vektorfonds gearbeitet. Es gab eine Vektor-
Aber jetzt um diese Formeln zu machen, ich meine, da gibt es ja, gut da geht es eigentlich über den Font hinaus, so ne große Klammer und so ein Wurzelzeichen, da müssen ja wirklich Linien gezogen werden.
Es gab eine Vektor-Beschreibung dieser Fonts, ja, und die wurde aber umgesetzt in Bitmaps. Und das war damals, da waren die Rechner nicht leistungsfähig genug, das on the fly zu machen.
Und für die Formeln?
Und die wurden vorberechnet. Da hat man dann, beispielsweise so etwas wie eine runde Klammer, das gibt etwas, wo man oben einen Teil hat, dann hat man so kleine Stücke einander gesetzt, unten einen Teil, das sieht man hier, die kann man so einander setzen, dass man sie sieht. Oder von den Summen, da wurde dann die Größe, die man braucht.
Aber das muss doch dann on demand gehen, weil das ist doch bei jeder Formel dann wieder ganz anders, wie die Klammer aussieht, oder?
Nein, die Klammern braucht man nicht. Die Summenzeichen sind das größere Problem, muss man sagen. Also da muss man einfach vertrauen, denn bei den Klammern glaubt man einfach. Ja, ich glaub dir alles. Nein, das Problem ist, dass wir das Medium, das nur zuhören, das nicht gut zeigen können, wie man das zusammensetzt. Aber bei Summenzeichen ist es ein größeres Problem und deswegen wurden Summenzeichen ganz am Anfang in den allerersten Versionen des Systems, wo es noch keine Vektor-Fonds gab, in 10 oder 20 Größeneinheiten erst mal hergestellt und falls man noch eine brauchte, weil man irgendwo entdeckt hat, man hat doch noch eine Zwischenstufe, dann hat man eben vorher das Fondgenerierungsprogramm angeworfen, das heißt Metafond, und hat sich ein Fond in der Zwischengröße, wie man ihn gebraucht hat, generiert, der dann als Bitmap anschließend vorlag, um dann diesen Fond wieder benutzen zu können.
Ah ja, okay, verstehe. Jetzt sind hier auch noch so Zeichnungen drin, wo so Zahlen in Kreise und Pfeilen und so weiter.
Ja, die Kreise, die gibt es dann auch in unterschiedlichen Größen.
Tabellen.
Und diese Einheiten, die muss man ja als Autor, wie haben wir eben gesagt, wir schreiben eine Datei, in der Datei schreiben wir rein, was wir haben wollen. Und nun kann man das auf der ganz untersten Ebene beginnen. Ich kann sagen, ich möchte gerne eine horizontale Linie, eine horizontale Box, nennen sie sich das, in der TeX-Jagdung, mit irgendwelchen Buchstaben drin haben. Und diese horizontale Box, die kann, möchte ich zusammen tun, das ist eine Zeile meines Weges, oder ein ganzer Absatz auch. Und die möchte ich dann vertikal in, mit anderen auffüllen. Das heißt, ich habe eine horizontal Box und ich kann viele von diesen Honsai-Boxen vertikal aneinander rein. Und da etwas, eine vertikale Box bauen. Und zwischen diese Boxen mache ich etwas, das nennt man Clue, Lime auf Deutsch. Das ist etwas, was so ein bisschen variabel ist, wo man den Ausgleich hinbekommt dadurch. Das heißt, wenn man ein Wort hat und zwischen den zwei Wörtern gibt es den weißen Platz, den Zwischenraum, und das nenne ich Clue. Und dieser Clue kann größer und kleiner werden. Und damit macht man seinen eigenen Umbruch. Und die aller unterste Ebene, die primitivste Ebene der TeX-Anweisungen, wo ich mit TeX auch als Programm arbeiten kann und als Programmierer arbeiten kann, wo ich TeX als Programmiersprache anfange, ich gebe dem Gerät Befehle. Ich sage, jetzt setzt du ein A, jetzt machst du irgendwo einen Zwischenraum und jetzt setzt du ein B. Und diese Ebene ist da. Nur mit der kann man kein Buch schreiben. Das kann man vergessen. Und deswegen gibt es etwas, das nenne ich eine Makrosprache. Und damit kann man Sequenzen von solchen primitiven Befehlen einen Namen geben. Und diesen Namen, den kann man dann, und nun gibt es zwei Zielrichtungen, wo man hinlaufen kann. Man kann entweder sagen, ich mache, die eine Zielrichtung ist, ich baue mir erstmal eine Reihe von Primitiven auf. Weil momentan, wir haben angefangen ganz tief unten mit, wir setzen nur ein Zeichen. Das ist Nonsens. Damit will man nicht tun. Man möchte solche Befehle haben wie, ich setze eine Seitennummer auf eine Seite. Ich habe einen lebenden Kolumnentitel für die rechte und für die linke Seite. Das sind Dinge, die ich erst einmal auch als Setzer haben möchte. Das heißt, was man braucht, ist erstmal eine Basisbibliothek von Basisfunktionen, in denen wir aus dem purem Zeichensetzen hinauskommen. Und das ist das, was wir Plain-Tech nennen und das ist das, wo Knuth auch selber direkt mitarbeitet. Das heißt, Knuth selber schreibt seine Bücher als Setzer. Der benutzt nicht dieses High-Level, was sich eben als Autorenmöglichkeit angepriesen hat, sondern Knuth wirklich arbeitet als Setzer.
Das heißt, um eine Seiten-Nummer in Plain-Tech hinzubekommen, ist im Prinzip schon etwas Programmiertätigkeit in TeX erforderlich. Es gibt nicht das Feature-Seiten-Nummer so in Plain-Tech.
Nein, das gibt es nicht.
Das heißt, es gibt einfach einen Satz von Primitiven, den man sich zusammenbaut. Und das ist natürlich etwas, wenn man das selber geschrieben hat und wenn man genau weiß, worum es sich handelt, kriegt man das irgendwie mal eben mal so hin, weil man hat es ja nun selber gemacht.
Genau, und wenn man so ein Genie ist und dann aber so für normale Sterbliche wie unser eins, ist das nicht der Fall.
Und das schreit dann sozusagen nach Abstraktion. Da kommen wir auch gleich noch hin, aber mich interessiert jetzt sozusagen noch der Weg. Das heißt, ich gebe also jetzt sozusagen mein Buch ein, mit mehr oder weniger Komplexität. Ich meine, wenn man jetzt einfach mal so ein Hello World Beispiel machen wollen würde, dann wäre es sicherlich nicht sonderlich komplex.
Nein, das ist gar nicht komplex.
Was würde man dann reinschreiben in ein PlainTech Dokument, um einfach auf einer leeren Seite in der Mitte Hello Welt stehen zu haben, schön zentriert?
Schön zentriert. Ist das schon schwierig? Nein, das ist nicht schwierig. Da würde man sagen, wirklich PlainTech, würde man sagen, mache mir einen Clou mit einer beliebig großen, was ist denn die deutsche Sitzung für Stretchability? Flexibilität, Dehnbarkeit. Dehnbarkeit ist eine gute deutsche Sitzung dafür. Mit einer beliebig großen Dehnbarkeit mache rechts, dann beginnt ein Absatz.
Also der Clou ist sozusagen dieser Abstand von oben bis zu dieser Zentrierung. Das heißt, so ein Gummiband.
Genau, so ein Gummiband. Und hinterher, wenn wir das Techniksystem näher gehen und alle Gummibänder, die es hat, nehmen und den verfügbaren Platz über diese Gummibänder aufteilen. Wenn wir also oben einen Gummiband eingeben, unten einen Gummiband eingeben und links und rechts auch einen Gummiband eingeben und dann wird er sehen, wir haben jetzt das, so und so breit, wir müssen nämlich beginnen zu sagen, wie breit unsere Seite ist. Wenn wir es im Plain-Tech haben, müssen wir sagen, wir hätten gerne eine Zentimeter auf 29,7 cm.
Was schreibe ich da, um das zu sagen?
Da ist solche Auszeichnungen, beginnen mit dem umgekehrten Schrägstrich. Das ist so eine Backslash auf Englisch. Da würde man hinschreiben, Backslash H-Size ist gleich 21 cm, cm. Man würde hinschreiben, Backslash V-Size ist gleich 29,7 cm. Und dann würde man hinschreiben, Backslash V-Fil. Was bedeutet, setze hier eine vertikale Füllung ein, so viel wie hinter Platz ist.
Vertikales Gummiband.
Vertikales Gummiband. Dann würde man hinschreiben, Backslash No Indent. Das bedeutet, ich beginne jetzt einen Absatz.
Warum No Indent?
Weil ich das auf der... Normalerweise haben Absätze einen Einzug. Das ist, wenn man einen normalen Absatz in so einem Buch anschaut, der erste Teil eines Absatzes ist leicht eingerückt.
Davon geht die Fault immer aus?
Das ist eine Fault-Einstellung, die da ist.
Das ist heutzutage gar nicht mehr so üblich, dass man so was so formatiert, wenn man sich die normale Textflut anschaut. Da beginnen ja Absätze eigentlich...
Ach, wenn ich mir die Bücher anschaue, das ist ein normales Buch. Wenn ich ein bliebiges Buch rausnehme, ein Taschenbuch.
Also im Buchsatz ist es üblich?
Ja, im Zeitungsatz ist es weniger üblich, aber im Buchsatz ist es nach wie vor üblich.
Das man einfach schnell erkennt, hier fängt ein Absatz an.
Genau.
Okay, und dann muss man sozusagen explizit sagen...
Weil ich möchte das zentriert haben auf meine komplette Zeile, und dann sage ich, okay, nun mache ich ein horizontales Auffüllen, dann würde ich Hello World hinschreiben oder Hello Welt nochmal horizontal auffüllen, weil wenn ich das Zweite vergessen würde, dann würde er mir das Ganze nämlich rechtsbündig machen, weil er dann nur einen Teil hätte, wo er was aufzufüllen hat. Und dann schreibe ich ihm V-Fill und dann schreibe ich ihm Backslash By.
Und das war's?
Das war's.
Das ist Hello World in Plain-Text, Vinzenz Intuit auf einer leeren Seite.
Ja, und das ist allerdings etwas, wobei ich kein Buch schreiben möchte, um das klar zu sagen.
Ist klar, aber bevor wir jetzt auf die Vereinfachung kommen, wollte ich nochmal so die Phase durchgehen. Also jetzt bleiben wir einfach mal bei diesem Hello World-Dokument. Das lege ich dann ab in einer.tex-Datei.
Genau, jawohl.
Und werfe es dann welchen Programm zum Fraß vor?
Heutzutage werft man es etwas vor, das heißt pdf.tex. Und herauskommt eine pdf-Datei.
Das heißt, es gibt für ein bestimmtes Ausgabeformat ein optimiertes TeX-Compiler?
Ja genau, ein Compiler kann man hier sagen. Das heißt, er nimmt diese Datei und erzeugt daraus das Gedruckte. Es gibt momentan zwei Dinge.
Aber Knuth hat es ja nicht so gemacht. Er hat jetzt sein Buch gehabt, dann stand da mein Buch.tex.
Zu Knuths Zeiten hat das TeX eine Zwischendatei ausgegeben, die hieß dvi. Das heißt, aus dem hello-welt.tex wurde hello-welt.dvi und dann gab es ein zweites Programm. Das weitere Programm hat es dann in die zugehörige Druckeranweisung umgesetzt. Das hieß dann dvi nach PostScript oder dvi nach, wie auch immer. Device-independent.
Also eine geräteunabhängige Darstellung.
Eine Low-Level-Darstellung, die sagt, was kommt wohin auf die Seite.
Und was ist das? Ist das im Prinzip nichts anderes als eine binäre Form, eine kondensierte Form von dem, was eigentlich in dem TeX auch drin steht? Das heißt, aus diesen ganzen Glue-Markern werden eigentlich auch nur Glue-Marker?
Nein, da stehen Positionen drin.
Das heißt, da ist es sozusagen schon für die jeweilige Seite fertig ausgerechnet. Genau. Da steht dann wirklich so, damit das zentriert ist, also da steht nicht mehr ein V-Fill, sondern da steht dann sozusagen fertig kalkuliert muss, was weiß ich, 15 Zentimeter.
Das steht da drin. Und das Ding hat also einen Koordinatenraster, das liegt dann irgendwie bei einem 1,65 Tausendstel Punkt. Ein Punkt ist ungefähr ein Drittel Millimeter. Das heißt, wir haben so als kleinster Einheit ein 180 Tausendstel Millimeter, das ist im Angstdrehenbereich.
Ein Punkt ist vor allem ein 72 Zoll. Das ist ja so die...
Genau, also ungefähr ein Drittel Millimeter. Das heißt, wir sind also bei ungefähr 180 Tausendstel Millimeter. Das ist die Größeneinheit, in der die Positionierungen in dieser DVI vorliegen, das ist die Größeneinheit, in der TeX rechnet. Und da steht dann drin, der A kommt dahin, an die Koordinaten, das B kommt an die Koordinaten. Und dadurch hat man in dieser DVI-Datei...
Beziehungsweise das H, das A und so weiter.
Und stehen gehabt, wo kommen welche Buchstaben hin. Und das kann dann so ein DVI-Treiber... Und außerdem steht noch drin in dieser DVI-Datei, welche Fonts werden benutzt. Und die Aufgabe des DVI-Treibers ist es nun, diese Informationen, welche Buchstaben werden wo ausgegeben auf der Seite, mit den Fonts zu... Die sagen, wie sehen die Buchstaben aus, gemeinsam zusammenzufassen und daraus dann eine Datei, also entweder eine Anzeige auf dem Bildschirm zu machen direkt, dass man das Ganze auf dem Bildschirm anzeigen kann, oder eine zweite Datei zu erzeugen, die den Druckerspezifischen Ausgabecode enthält. Bei Satzsystemen ist das häufig ein proprietäres Format, muss man klar sehen, oder früher, mittlerweile, alles in PDF. Und das ist halt die Änderung, die hat sich ergeben vor, naja, ich würde sagen, vor vier Jahren, fünf Jahren. Und in dieser Größenordnung muss man sehen, dass die Bedeutung von so einem Zwischenformat wie DVI vollkommen abgenommen hat. Das ist mittlerweile etwas, wo in ganz, ganz wenigen Spezialfeldern man auf DVI machen möchte.
Das wird jetzt im Prinzip von PDF übernommen.
PDF ist zurzeit das standardisierte Format, mit dessen Hilfe man das macht. Und auch da ist es so, dass eben TeX eines der Möglichkeiten ist, wirklich hochkontrativen PDF mit Druckoptimierung.
Aber es ist wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal auszuschließen, dass DVI auch an der Stelle Ideengeber war für PDF.
Nee, PDF kommt aus einem Postscript raus.
Ja, aber PDF ist ja ganz anders als Postscript.
Nein, PDF ist Postscript, eine ganz vereinfachtes Postscript, wo man mit Postscript Objekte definieren kann.
Ja, also gut, bitte jetzt nicht verkompliziert, Postscript ist ja eine Programmiersprache, PDF ist keine, in PDF ist das sozusagen statisch festgehalten, das sind sozusagen Datenstrukturen, wo es bei Postscript halt ein Programm ist, was diese Datenstrukturen erzeugt. Sie haben ja beide sozusagen das selbe Imaging-Modell, aber sie sind ja an sich nicht vergleichbar. Ich will das jetzt gar nicht so weit vertiefen.
Genau, das würde ich jetzt hier rausfallen.
Aber auch DVI ist keine Programmiersprache.
Nein.
Das heißt, TeX führt es in etwas Statisches über, was dann DVI war und genauso hat Postscript es halt in etwas überführt, was in PDF eben auch statisch beschrieben ist. Da fließt ja nichts mehr sozusagen.
Aber da gab es keine Querbezüge. Also wir haben zwar Kontakt mit den Adobe-Leuten, also wir meinen es die TeX-Developer-Community, aber das ist eher so, dass man mit denen über, ja, über Fonds und so Kontakt hat, beziehungsweise auch dessen, weil sie im Adobe Illustrator zum Teil TeX-Algorithmen eingesetzt haben. Das heißt, da sind dann so Querbezüge, also Algorithmen, die mit TeX zum ersten Mal gemacht wurden, nämlich wie macht man Abschatzumbruch und so etwas, die sind später in anderen Programmen auch gelandet.
So, das heißt, jetzt nochmal zu Knuth zurück. Jetzt hat er sein Buch geschrieben, hat es mit seinem TeX-Compiler übersetzt in eine DVI-Datei. Dann braucht er ja für dieses konkrete Belichter-System, was er dann als Buch macht, auch noch einen Treiber, der hat er wahrscheinlich auch selber geschrieben, nehme ich mal an.
Genau, er hat einen Mitarbeiter von ihm geschrieben.
Ach so, das hat er schon delegiert.
Ja, also diese DVI-Treiber, das, ich glaube, den ersten dürfte der Herr Fuchs geschrieben haben. Ja, also er ist bei einer Arbeitsgruppe, er hat dann nicht ganz alleine gearbeitet, sondern er ist ja als Professor an der University of Stanford tätig gewesen, bis er emeritiert wurde. Und zum Teil gab es dann auch Promotionsarbeiten, in denen z.B. die Frage, wie macht man Silbentrennung, ist etwas, was in Promotion war von einem seiner Mitarbeiter. Das heißt, wo ein neues theoretisches Verfahren ausgearbeitet wurde, hat sich dann auch der Ungeheuer Innovative, wie trennt man Wörter, sodass es möglichst wenig Fehler gibt dabei. Und das ist etwas, was wir heutzutage dann eben in TeX zuallererst wiedergefunden haben und später auch in anderen Programmen dieses Ergebnis hatte.
Das heißt also Absatzformatierung, dieses Kearning und Trennung ist auch Teil von Kern-TeX?
Das ist Teil der sogenannten TeX-Maschine.
Und auch so etwas wie jetzt Verweise auf andere Seiten, oder ist das jetzt schon so eine Metaebene, die nicht mehr durch TeX selber gemacht wird?
TeX selber stellt, wie ich eben gesagt habe, eine Art von Programmiersprache bereit. Und wir haben jetzt eine Maschine, das Ganze formatiert. Und man kann dieses Thema Verweise, wird mit Hilfe dieser Programmiersprache dann geregelt.
Okay, das heißt, das ist dann eigentlich schon etwas, also das könnte man sich selber programmieren.
Oder man nimmt eben das, was andere Leute für einen programmiert haben.
Weil da ist mir immer so ein Kernproblem. Ich meine, das kann ja jetzt passieren, was weiß ich. Ich habe so meine Einführungen, die schreibe ich jetzt so, blablabla, und mache einen Ausblick auf das nächste Kapitel. Und das findest du auf Seite, hm hm hm. Und dann geht es halt ein paar Absätze weiter, und dann kommt dann auch dieses Kapitel. Das ist aber dann, beginnt dann sozusagen am Ende von Seite 2. Und dadurch, dass ich aber jetzt, so, und dann weiß er, aha, okay, wenn ich jetzt da einen Verweis drauf mache, und ich will die Seitenzahl einfügen, dann muss ich halt auf diese Seite Nummer 2 sitzen, das ist jetzt ein blödes Beispiel, weil ich wollte jetzt auf bewusst etwas langsameres sagen, aber es ist irgendwie Seite 5348. Und jetzt müsste ich an dieser Stelle die 5348 einfügen. Dadurch verschiebt sich ja unter Umständen dann alles andere wieder nach hinten, sodass es eben nicht mehr auf dieser Seite ist, sondern auf dieser Seite plus eins. Das ist doch sicherlich ein Problem, an das Herr Knuth auch schon gedacht hat.
Das ist einfach mehrfaches Durchlaufen gelöst.
Das heißt, man stellt dann fest, oh, Umbruch, und dann...
Wenn man solche Vorwärtsreferenzen hat, dann wird erstmal zwei Fragezeichen ausgegeben, so nach dem Motto, das kommt schon ungefähr hin. Und dann wird sich gemerkt, wo kommt denn der Umbruch hin? Und dann gibt es das... Beim zweiten Durchlauf weiß man ja, wo der Vorwärtsverweis hingegangen ist. Dann kann man die Seitennummer einsetzen. Und in der Praxis kommt es nicht vor, dass man mehr als dreimal durchlaufen muss.
Aber ich dachte mir dann, wenn es dann eine andere Zahl ist, und dann wird dann aus einer Null eine Eins, dann ist auf einmal wieder genug Platz, dann rutscht es wieder nach vorne oder so?
Nein, das passiert deswegen nicht, weil Ziffern im Allgemeinen gleich breit sind. Und der Austausch von der Null gegen die Eins wird den Umbruch nicht verändern.
Also gerade noch gerettet, würde ich sagen.
Wobei es schon passieren kann. Es kann sein, dass beim zweiten Mal... Also normalerweise ist es schon so, dass man in dem Augenblick...
Also es kann ja auch von 9.999 auf 10.000 irgendwie umschlagen.
Und es gibt sogar... Man könnte theoretisch sogar pathologische Fälle konstruieren, dass wenn man es dann nach hinten schiebt, dann wird er da vorne andere Zahlen einsetzen muss und man eine Endlosschleife hinbekommt. Aber man muss klar sehen...
Also ich müsste mich jetzt eigentlich in meinen Kämmerlein setzen und versuchen, so einen pathologischen Fall hinzubekommen, dann kriege ich auch einen Check von Knuth.
Nein, da bekomme ich keinen Check von Knuth. Weil das ist nichts, etwas, das er als Teil... Dieser ist eine inhärende Sache, dass die Formatierung da macht... Sein Antwort würde sein, bitte umformulieren.
Das heißt, ich muss mich eigentlich eher an den entsprechenden Menschen, dessen Makropaket ich dann verwendet habe.
Genau, genau. Und die stellen keine Checkliste aus.
So, so. Das ist ja auch alles nur... Nur Sein und Schein hier.
Genau.
Jetzt denke ich, haben wir auch ganz gut erfasst. Ich habe es jetzt verstanden, was sozusagen das Plain-Tech, den eigentlichen Chor und damit eben den eigentlichen Beitrag von Knuth betrifft, das Satzsystem. Jetzt ist offensichtlich so, wie wir eben dieses Hello World eingegeben haben, will man eigentlich nicht arbeiten. Das ist etwas, was einem vom Buchschreiben dann doch wieder wegbringt.
Was man eigentlich tun möchte, es gibt zwei Punkte, was man tun möchte.
Ach so, warte mal. Was ich noch gehört habe, es gibt doch Versionsnummern von diesem TeX-Code. Und die sind komisch.
Für einen Mathematiker sind sie nicht komisch. Sie konvergieren gegen Pi.
Das heißt, die erste Version war... Die erste Version war eins.
Die war eins, genau. Und gab es zwei, drei, dann gab es 3,1, dann gab es 3,14, dann gab es 3,4, 1, 1, genau und so weiter. Und mittlerweile ziehen wir da jetzt mal weiter und der Knuth hat in seinem Testament hinterlegt, dass sobald er stirbt, das Ganze zu Pi umbrannt wird. Dann hat TeX die Version Pi.
Weil es keine neue Version mehr gibt, weil er lässt dann niemanden mehr ran?
Genau. Wie gesagt, das ist eine Trademarkssache. Man kann TeX ändern. TeX wurde auch geändert. Das von mir vorhin, den genannten PTF-TeX, heißt deswegen so, weil es ein geändertes TeX ist. Die Originalversion von Knuth ist immer noch die, die die DVI ausgibt. Die nützt nur, ich glaube, ich kenne keinen, der die wirklich benutzt, noch groß. Sondern man benutzt heutzutage PTF-TeX. Das ist eine geänderte Variante. Und Knuth hat erlaubt, dass man diesen Begriff TeX übrigens geschrieben, sieht aus wie T-E-X, heißt aber Tau Epsilon Chi. Das sind die drei griechischen Buchstaben, die von Technik kommen, was im Griechischen eine Kombination von Handwerk und Kunst bedeutet. Und das ist das, wo er das Ganze gesehen hat, wo er die Typografie in einen Satz sieht, als eine Mischung von Handwerk und Kunst. Und deswegen wird es auch so komisch ausgesprochen. Das ist nicht, wie gesagt, das sind keine drei lateinischen Buchstaben. Es sind eigentlich drei griechische Buchstaben. Tau Epsilon Chi. Als Abkitzung von Technik.
Und deswegen ist die Korrekt der Aussprache TeX.
Ja, weil Chi eben wie das Buch, also wie CH im Buch ausgesprochen wird. Und so kommt diese komische Aussprache zustande. Und wenn man alles geschrieben sieht, sieht man immer nur TeX dastehend und jeder denkt Puh, was ist da los? Aber zurück zu dem Thema, das da ist. Wir arbeiten an dem System schon weiter. Das System wird weiterentwickelt. Aber nicht mehr von Knuth. Und so wie ich irgendwo, wenn ich Firefox in einer Linux Debian-Distribution habe, das Ding nicht mehr Firefox heißt, weil die selber dann ändern wollen und die nennen es dann, wie heißt es, Eiswiesel oder sonst irgendetwas. So wird halt in dem Augenblick, wenn man das TeX umändert, muss man dafür einen anderen Namen nehmen. Das ist etwas, was ja auch heutzutage in der Open-Source-Welt doch nicht nur eine einmalige Aktion oder eine unübliche Aktion ist. Und nun, wenn man mit TeX arbeiten möchte, gibt es eigentlich zwei Sorten Leute, die mit TeX arbeiten möchte. Autoren und Setzer. Und die haben schon verschiedene Sichtweise drauf. Ein Autor, also jemand wie du vielleicht, wie ich, wie jemanden, der in der Uni ist und mit Globarmat schreiben möchte, jemanden, der irgendwo ein Buch schreiben möchte, das irgendwo auch im geisteswissenschaftlichen Zuhause ist, wo er sehr viele, wie gesagt, Querverweise hat, jemanden, der ein Buch auch in Sprachen, in vielen Sprachen schreiben möchte, die ansonsten von anderen Systemen nicht entschützt werden. Sagen wir zum Beispiel in Khmer oder in Hindi oder in irgendeiner anderen Sprache, eine Schriftform, die unüblich ist. Berber, zum Beispiel ein Projekt gehabt, wo Bücher geschrieben wurden, in den alten Sagen der Berber weitergegeben wurden, auch in der Schrift der Berber. Das sind Punkte da, die wollen dann was anderes. Die wollen sagen, ich beginne ein Dokument. Das Dokument ist ein Buch oder ist ein Artikel. Für die in die Zeitschrift vielleicht. Dann weiß man schon, wie das aussehen soll. Wenn ich hergehe und habe einen Artikel, der in der Wissenschaftsschrift erscheint, dann bestimme ich als Autor nicht, wie das aussieht. Das bestimmt die Zeitschrift für mich. Da schreibe ich also hin, das ist ein Artikel für Zeitschrift XYZ. Und dann sage ich, ich beginne mein Dokument. Dann kommt meine Überschrift hin. Dann sage ich, hier soll meine Inhaltsversorgung hin. Und das passiert immer noch mit diesen Backslash-Dingern da. Wie ich eben gesagt habe, der umgekehrte Schrägstich in deiner Tei-Tei-Tei steht da. Backslash, Table of Contents. Diese Namen sind Englisch dann.
Also wir reden jetzt von der nächsten Ebene auf TeX.
Genau, das ist das, wie man als Autor arbeitet.
Und das ist das, was man ein Makrosystem für TeX nennt.
Genau.
Und da gibt es vor allem?
Zwei Stück zurzeit. Eine ist LaTeX, das hat eine Zielgruppe Autoren, die selber Bücher schreiben wollen. Und das zweite heißt Context. Und Context hat als Zielgruppe Leute, die auch in den Satz explizit eingreifen wollen. Context ist geschaffen worden von jemand namens Hans Hagen, der in Niederlande ist und der dort eine Firma hat, Pragma, und der sein Geld damit verdient, Bücher zu machen. Also wirklich auch so klassisch mit Ausschreibungen. Es gibt dann irgendwelche Schulbücher oder sonstige Dinge. Und die setzen TeX ein, weil sie damit billiger und schneller sind als die Leute, die das Ganze irgendwo mit Quark, Express oder was auch immer machen. Und weil sie mit den Hilfsmitteln, die sie haben, das schnell machen können. Und für den als Setzer ist so ein Autoren-System nicht das Ziel der Wahl. Sondern der bekommt die Anforderung, dass er zu einem Text, den ein Autor irgendwo schon mal erfasst hat und der dann einfach nur als Datei vorlegt, dann soll der ein spezielles Layout für den Verlag herstellen, als Satzbüro. Und das heißt, der braucht etwas anderes. Und das sind diese beiden, ich habe vorhin von dem Building, von dem Baugrund, von dem Untergrund plane-technisch gesprochen, auf die wir jetzt zwei unabhängige und auch von der Benutzung her vollkommen inkompatible Stück oben draufsetzen. LaTeX für Autoren und Context für Leute, die sich intensiver noch darum kümmern möchten, was kommt wohin in meinem Buch. Und die also aus dem Bereich des TeX-Satzes sind. Wobei da auch wiederum, Hans, schon mit der Zeit in Kontext Dinge eingelaufen sind, dass man da jetzt nicht den... Lassen Sie mich einfach... Es gibt dann Leute, die haben das Kontext entdeckt. Und auch die wollten damit Bücher machen. Aber mit mehr Kontrolle über das Layout. Und deswegen hat das Kontext mittlerweile so weit gewachsen, dass auch im Kontext wir Anteile wiederfinden, die gesagt, hier ist eine Überschrift da. Aber ursprünglich war das Ganze gesagt, okay, ich habe hier einen Aufteil meiner Seite, ich habe einen Grid, in den etwas einfließen muss. Und diese viel bessere und höhere Kontrolle, das Ganze, das ist, was Kontext ausmacht. Wohingegen LaTeX eher aus dem, ja, ursprünglich aus dem universitären Umfeld, im Forschungsumfeld herauskommt. Und in diesem Umfeld ging es eher darum, ich will nur meinen Inhalter hinschreiben. Und jemand anderes kümmert sich um meinen Layout.
Das heißt, man kann sagen, LaTeX ist jetzt eigentlich sozusagen das Default-Interface, wenn man jetzt nicht irgendein anderes Hilfsprogramm verwendet, sondern wenn man sozusagen in TeX ein Dokument, primär sagen wir jetzt mal ein Buch oder was buchartiges, erfassen will, dann nimmt man LaTeX. Und LaTeX ist dann eine Sammlung von Makros sozusagen. Das heißt, ich schreibe immer noch in dieser TeX-artigen Syntax mit Backslash-Tralala irgendetwas hin. Aber es ist eben sehr viel abstrakter, eine Meter Ebenen drüber, und wird dann von LaTeX in konkrete TeX-Sachen gemacht. Ich kann sagen, diese Zeile ist zentriert, und dann fällt dem TeX irgendwas raus mit zwei Gummibändern.
Ja gut, selbst das tue ich nicht mal, zentrierte Zeile. Ich sag wirklich dann meistens nur noch, okay, ich habe hier eine, weil, wann willst du hinschreiben, dass was zentriert ist? Das wäre schon wieder als Autor. Was willst du machen? Was du eigentlich sagen willst? Ich habe hier zum Beispiel eine Zitat. Und ob das Zitat hinterher, ich zitiere etwas, ob das eigentlich zentriert ist, das ist etwas, was dir in dem Moment als Autor, wenn du dich in deinem Inhalt konzentrierst, egal sein kann. Also was man im LaTeX macht, man sagt, ich beginne...
Mir würde da jetzt schon ein Beispiel einfallen, aber ich verstehe, was du sagen willst.
Was wir in LaTeX machen, ist sagen, ich beginne ein Zitat, das heißt dann so was, wir beginnen Quote und ich ende ein Zitat. End Quote. Und zwischendurch habe ich mein Zitat. Und ob das Zitat dann etwas ist, was rechtsbündig, linksbündig zentriert da ist, das ist etwas, das dann...
Von wem festgelegt wird?
Von den sogenannten Styles festgelegt wird. Dann kann ich entweder jemand anders, oder ich in einer anderen Arbeitsphase, ich kann nun diesen Auszeichnungen, diese Informationen über meine Dokumentenstruktur kann ich nun Formatierungen zuordnen. Ich kann sagen, ich gebe dann solche Pakete, die nennen sie ja genau LaTeX-Pakete, und von denen gibt es eine riesige Menge davon, also ein paar hundert, wo man dann solche, so eine Art Bausteine hat, wo man die raussucht. Dann gibt es dann welche, womit meine Zitate dann in Kursiv, oder wo ich eine Konfigurationsdatei hinschreiben kann, auch zur Not, wo ich sage, ich hätte gerne mein Zitat mit Kursiv statt in normalen Schreibschrift, normalen Romanschrift, wie ich hier habe, oder dass ich sage, ich hätte sie gerne zentriert. Und das sind dann Aktionen, die eben mir von den Entwicklern dieser Packages, dieser Pakete vorgeliefert werden. Und das ist das, was auch das Ökosystem, dieses LaTeX ausmacht. Das für fast alle Probleme, die man da irgendwo als vorfindet, die man hat als Autor, wo ich irgendetwas brauche, was so und so ist, irgendjemand in den letzten 27 Jahren dieses Problem auch schon mal gehabt hat. Und dann gibt es dann dafür eben ein Paket. Und ich gehe eben auf die...
Das ist ein Paket, was die entsprechenden Styles mitbringt.
Genau.
Und aber auch unter Umständen noch neue Makros.
Genau. Das Pakete bringen dann zum Teil auch so neue Auszeichen, neue Makros mit. Also dass ich halt dann eben nicht nur einen beginnen Quot habe, sondern da gibt es eben meinetwegen ein Paket, das auch so einen eigenen Namen für... Jetzt fällt mir kein gutes Beispiel momentan. Also es gibt ein Paket, womit ich sagen kann, ich möchte etwas wirklich nur ein Programmlisting abdrucken. So ein Computerbuch, das ich machen möchte. Und dann möchte ich etwas, was irgendwo ein C-Programm oder ein Java-Programm ist.
Oder Kommandozahle-Eingabe.
Oder Kommandozahle-Eingabe. Und da gibt es ein Pakete, dann sagt, ok, jetzt beginne ich mein Programmlisting, jetzt ändere ich mein Programmlisting. Und das Ding macht sogar voll automatische Formatierungen zwischendrin. Das heißt, wenn man dann so sein C-Programm eingibt, dann werden dann die C-Schlüsselwörter in Fett geschrieben und die Variablen in Kursiv geschrieben. Automatisch. Also wo man sagen kann, ok, ich beginne hier und ich muss mich nicht darum kümmern, dass ich dann mein If und mein Else etwas in Fett habe und muss das markieren und dann auf meinen Bolt-Knopf drücke.
Aber das sind ja dann schon komplexe Algorithmen, die dann auch in irgendeiner anderen Programmiersprache geschrieben sind. Das heißt, das ist dann immer auch die Frage, wie portabel ist das jetzt auf andere Systeme. Man muss also schon schauen, wenn man so ein Paket verwendet, dass das dann eben auf dem jeweiligen Betriebssystem, was man zum Einsatz bringt, zu laufen kommt?
Nein, das ist immer das gleiche. Das läuft überall.
Warum?
Weil es in der TeX-Makrosprache steht.
Also das ist vollständig in TeX?
Das ist vollständig in TeX.
In TeX schreibt man Code, der so komplex ist, dass er C, automatisch, mit Dax-Highlighting und so weiter.
Oder auch kritische Editionen.
Ist denn TeX Touring Complete?
Ja, ist Touring Complete.
Das heißt, es ist eigentlich eine richtige Programmiersprache, in der man auch Computerspiele programmieren kann.
Genau, jawohl.
Hat das auch schon mal jemand gemacht?
Es hat jemand mal einen Basic in der Bräder in TeX geschrieben.
Super, wo man dann seinen Texte-Brescher zum Laufen kriegt. Naja, vielleicht läuft es nicht schnell, aber es sieht dann bestimmt gut aus, wenn man es austrungen kann.
Wobei man sagen muss, momentan gibt es gerade auch da eine Erweiterung, die entstehen ist. Das ist eine der aktuellsten Entwicklungen in der TeX-Community. Lua, sagt der das was?
Das ist so eine Programmiersprache.
Genau, das ist das momentane, halbe Lieblingsding, der wir beten eine Programmiersprache irgendwo ein. Das heißt, wenn man ein Programm hat, eine Anwendung hat, und die möchte man um programmierbare Anteile erweitern, dann wird heutzutage sehr viel Lua benutzt. Das ist eine Programmiersprache, die sehr klein in der Implementierung ist, aber sehr mächtig ist. Und da gibt es nun diverse Leute, das sind auch wiederum die Leute, die Kontext entwickelt haben, die daran intensiv arbeiten, Lua in TeX einzubetten. Das ist dieses Jahr in der diesjährigen Distribution zum ersten Mal auch dabei, sodass man dann nicht mehr in der TeX-Makrosprache die recht schwer zu programmieren. Das muss man dazusagen. Das ist eine der Nachteile von TeX. Also eine der ganz großen Nachteile von TeX ist, dass diese Makrosprache so schwer ist. Sie ist zwar hinterher einfach zu benutzen, aber sie zu programmieren, ist nicht unbedingt das Allereinfachste der Welt. Weil Makrosprachen etwas auch ist, was in der Ausbildung, Programmierausbildung heutzutage kaum jemand mehr kennt. Das ist etwas, was ein Konzept der 80er, der frühen 80er, der Ende der 70er ist. Und Lua ist eher moderner Programmiersprache, wodurch es hoffentlich einfacher werden wird, und dass man schneller lernen kann.
Und die auch dafür gebaut ist, im Beditz zu werden. Das wird ja auch bei vielen anderen Sachen kommt zum Einsatz. Ein populäres Beispiel ist World of Warcraft, wo es sozusagen Scriptsprache ist, um Systeme zu automatisieren, innerhalb des Systems.
Und das ist eben etwas, wo man in Zukunft die Abbildung dessen, wie passt man jetzt seinen C-Code, um das Fett und kursiv zuzuweisen und die Eindrückungen zu bestimmen und solche Dinge. Das ist dann etwas, das wird dann in Lua machbar sein. Und das ist momentan wie gesagt in der TeX-Makrosprache gemacht. Und diese... Ja, und das ist das, was die Styles dann zur Verfügung stellen. Ja, und eingeben...
Ich glaube, das wurde sogar, ich habe auch schon mal, kann ich wieder ein bisschen Eigenwerbung machen, die CRE 73, dreht sich ja rund um World of Warcraft und ich glaube, da kam der Lua-Aspekt auch kurz zur Sprache, aber ich glaube nicht, dass wir da besonders tief drauf eingegangen sind. Gut, also das heißt, Lua ist jetzt quasi auf dem Weg in das Tech-Universum, um dort das Problem der Automatisierung und komplexer Makros, sozusagen, zu vereinfachen, damit man eben...
Für mehr Leute zugänglich zu machen. Weil der Lernaufwand, diese Makrosprache zu lernen, der ist relativ hoch. Zum Glück muss man als Autor, den, wie gesagt, nicht haben, weil dann müssen nur diejenigen machen, die diese Makropakete schreiben, diese LaTeX-Pakete oder...
Aber auch da will man natürlich mehr Flexibilität haben.
Man möchte auch mehr Leute haben, die da mitarbeiten. Man muss sehen, schon sehen, wir haben, wie in fast...
Unvorher selber ist halt wenig Ballast. Das ist ein sehr kleiner Kern.
Wir haben, wie in so vielen dieser Communities, eine gewisse Menge von Leuten, die entwickeln. Und das sind gar nicht mal so viele. Und es gibt sehr, sehr viele Leute, die es benutzen. Und was die Einstiegsbarriere geringer macht, dass mehr Leute mitentwickeln, in so einem Open-Source-Projekt, ist besser, muss man ganz klar sehen. Umso einfacher der Einstieg ist, umso besser ist es. Wobei ich noch mal auf einen Punkt zurückkommen will, nämlich das Thema, ich gebe das in die Datei ein, diese Backslash-Tralala, wie du vorhin schon gesagt hast. Man kann das natürlich irgendwo mit seinem Editor, der im schlimmsten Fall Notparteit heißt, da eingeben. Das möchte man aber eigentlich nicht. Was man eigentlich möchte, ist, dass man eine Eingabemetode hat, wo man irgendwo aus dem Menü auswählt und sagt aus dem Menü, ich hätte jetzt hier gerne eine Überschrift oder ich hätte jetzt hier gerne eine Tabelle oder so. Das ist das, wie auch die meisten Leute, die ich kenne, arbeiten. Dabei gibt es zum einen ein System namens LüX, L-Y-X geschrieben, das eine Microsoft-Office-ähnliche Oberfläche für LaTeX bereitstellt, wo man dann auch schon so in etwa sieht, wie es aussieht hinterher. Nicht ganz genau, aber so in etwa. Und für die Leute, die eher noch diese Backdress-Sequenz sehen wollen, aber nicht so wie beim HTML editieren. Ich hatte ja vorhin diese Vergleichung mit HTML gemacht. Auch da gibt es die Editoren, die vollkommen Visivic sind. Und es gibt welche, wo man zwar die Hilfen hat, aber trotzdem den HTML-Code noch hat. Und da kann man auch sehen, dass sobald jemand eine Weile lang HTML schreibt, der dann doch irgendwann wieder übrigens bei den Editoren landet, die das nicht Visivic machen, aber wo Eingabehilfen da sind. Das heißt, wo man dann nicht die spitze Klammer per Hand hinschreibt, sondern wo man irgendwo ein Menü hat, das sagt, ich will jetzt hier eine Liste haben. Und das macht mir als meine Basis, mein Beginnliste, erster Listenpunkt, Ende Liste hin. Und da ist ein ganz innen weit genutztes System, Emacs, mit einer Erweiterung, die AUGTECH heißt, AUCTECH geschrieben. Und das ist etwas, womit man dann zum Teil wirklich den Preview bei der Eingabe schon hat, also wenn man das eingibt, dann sieht man direkt schon die Formel, die man eingibt. Man wird da nicht hergehen und nur noch abstrakte Bechslischcodes eingeben, sondern man sagt dann in dem Menü, okay, ich möchte jetzt hier meine Überschrift haben und die Überschrift kommt dann auch schon etwas größer raus.
Ich denke, das sollte noch mal am Ende ein bisschen mehr Raum bekommen, was es da noch für Tools gibt. Da gibt es ja sicherlich noch ein paar andere Empfehlenswerte. Ich würde ganz gerne noch mal so ein bisschen bei LaTeX bleiben, weil das ja nun eigentlich auch das, was ich jetzt richtig verstanden habe, das ist eigentlich das, was man erst mal lernen sollte. Wenn man also wirklich nah ran möchte, die volle Kraft entfalten möchte, die es TeX kann, ohne sich jetzt gleich den Wahn von PlainTeX zu geben, kann man natürlich auch machen.
Das würde ich auf keinen Fall empfehlen.
Na ja, es ist für angehende Informatiker sicherlich auch mal ein interessanter Kurs. Wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall LaTeX ist das, was... Er ist ja auch die Begegnung mit der Vergangenheit und der Inkarnation der Perfektion. Wie auch immer. Also LaTeX ist sozusagen das Rüstzeug, was man lernen soll. Wie umfangreich muss man sich das jetzt vorstellen? Also Makros, klar, Seitennummern hatten wir schon. War es das schon? Was ist drin in LaTeX? Was bekomme ich für einen Werkzeugkasten auf den Tisch gestellt, um jetzt ein Buch zu schreiben? Weil ich muss auch sagen, ich muss mir selber persönlich immer vorwerfen, dass ich mir nie wirklich Zeit genommen habe, mich mal mit TeX auseinanderzusetzen, obwohl ich eigentlich auch ein totaler Schreib-Nerd bin. Ich habe lange Dokumente gemacht und natürlich hat man immer dieses Problem mit der fehlenden Semantik. Du hast ja auch schon angesprochen, wenn ich so ein Wort nehme oder so, wie sie auch alle heißen, die haben halt alle zwar im Ansatz irgendwie mehr oder weniger Formatvorlagen. Da kann man auch mal sagen, das ist dann irgendwie so eine Überschrift und die einen sind besser, und die anderen, ich bin dann irgendwann mal bei FrameMaker hängen geblieben.
FrameMaker ist mit Sicherheit eins der wirklich guten Systeme dabei.
Ich würde sagen, FrameMaker war so gut, dass es einen davon abhalten konnte, es mit TeX zu machen.
Ja, also FrameMaker ist auch eine exzellente Ausgabequalität. Also deutlich besser als die von Office oder so.
Und vor allem, da konnte man halt auch sehr semantisch drin denken. Benutzt man die Vergangenheit, weil ich benutze auf Macs, gibt es derzeit nur noch unter Windows, was ich regelmäßig beklage und beheule. Leider wurde die Software selber nicht wirklich auch in die Moderne getragen. Da fehlt eigentlich sozusagen auch noch an der Stelle so die Killer-Applikation, die eben diese Verbindung schlägt. Aber trotzdem, wenn ich jetzt sage, okay, alles klar, ich weiß, das würde sagen, vor allem bei technischer Dokumentation ist das wirklich so ein richtiges, richtiges Megaproblem. Dass man ja eigentlich so logisch, wie das System zu beschreiben ist, was ich eben konkret dokumentieren möchte, so logisch möchte ich auch gerne mein Dokument selbst angehen. Ich möchte gerne die inherente Logik, die ich ausdrücke, möchte ich auch in meinem Dokument drin haben. Die Dinge sollen strukturiert sein. Wie du schon gesagt hast, so die Beispiele, Zitate, also ich will halt immer sagen, was ist es? Was ist jetzt drin in LaTeX? Was erhalte ich für einen Werkzeugkasten? Wie attraktiv ist das jetzt, wenn ich überlege, welches Tool soll ich nehmen, um eine technische Dokumentation oder ein Buch zu schreiben?
Was man bekommt, sind Werkzeugkasten, in denen zum einen mal vorgefertigt drin sind, alle strukturierte Dokumente zu haben. Das heißt, welche, die mit Abschnitten sind, mit Unterabschnitten, mit Unterunterabschnitten usw. In der Basisauslieferung geht das bis auf die fünfte Ebene runter. Wenn man mehr als fünf Ebenen haben möchte, muss man eine Sitzung Zusatzpakete machen. Dieses Paket ist aber auch bei der Auslieferung dabei. Es gibt mittlerweile eine Windows und eine weitere Auslieferung, die nennt sich TeX Live, die es für Unix und Mac gibt. Es gibt mittlerweile auch eine Windows-Variante. Diese Pakete sind mit enthalten. Es ist nicht so, dass ich mir nur ein LaTeX, wenn ich das installiere, oder wenn es bei mir schon irgendwo auf meinem Linux-Disputation dabei ist, bei vielen Linux-Disputationen ist es schon mit dabei, dann habe ich nicht nur das Scann-LaTeX, sondern dieses Zusatzpaket schon da. Wenn ich meine erste Einleitung lese, The General Introduction to LaTeX, da gibt es auch eine deutsche Übersetzung, deren Name ich nicht auswendig weiß, ist auch enthalten dann in einer Distribution. Und was bekomme ich da mit? Und da ist out of the box erst einmal bis zu 5 Tiefen. Die zugehörigen Dinge wie Inhaltsverzeichnis, wie lebender Kolumnentitel, das heißt, dass meine momentane Abschnittüberschrift dann erscheint, vielleicht auf der linken Seite, Kopfzeile, genau, linke Seite, nur die Kapitelüberschrift, rechte Zeile, die als aktuelle Unterabschnitt oder so etwas, das wird dann automatisch mitgemacht, genau. Wenn ich das dann noch anpassen möchte, was dahin, dann muss ich wieder so ein Paket, dann gibt es ein Paket dann wieder, wo ich dann ganz spezifisch sagen kann, ich hätte es nicht in der Kopfzeile, sondern ich möchte das irgendwo in der Fußzeile.
Also es gibt schon so ein typisches Default-Erscheinungsbild, woran man auch immer diese TeX-Dokumente eigentlich auch irgendwie erkennt. Also mir geht es so, ich schlage irgendwas auf, und dann weiß ich einfach, das ist jetzt TeX, und ich erkenne auch Word.
Ja, natürlich.
Also Word hat irgendwie so eine schlachsige Erscheinung.
Und das liegt daran, dass bei Word der Umbruch immer so schlecht ist.
Ja, Trennung und Desperating ist auch gut.
Genau. Und was bekommt man noch mit außerdem? Man bekommt mit Querverweise. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt sowohl auf Abschnitte, Fußnoten wahrscheinlich, Endnoten, die am Ende des Kapitels sind. Jawohl, das ist auch, die waren für mich so Essentials, dass ich da noch gar nicht nachgedacht habe. Die auch dann durchnummeriert werden können, Seitenweise oder Abschnittweise oder Buchweise oder so.
Wie hat auch Einfluss darauf, wie nummeriert wird?
Ja, man kann sagen, dass man sie entweder mit Buchstahls, mit Zeichen, es gibt auch solche Symbole, oder man kann sagen, man hätte sie gerne mit Nummern, dass sie nummeriert werden sollen. Das ist einstellbar, einfach. Das ist etwas, was man am Anfang seines Dokumentes entweder in einer eigenen Konfrontationsdatei oder am Anfang des Dokumentes irgendwo hinschreibt. Wo man dann so hinschreibt, ich hätte gerne meine Fußnoten statt mit Nummern, mit symbolischen Zeichen. Da werden so Kreuzchen genommen und irgendwelche Däcker, also Symbole, nennen sich das, das sind so Schwerzymbole kleine. Zapfdingbats. Genau, solche Dinge, die werden dafür genommen. Das ist etwas, was man als Autor häufig am Ende macht. Nachdem man so einen Text geschrieben hat, verlegt man sich dann auch, okay, ich möchte jetzt hier meine Fußnoten anders aussehen lassen. Oder zwischendurch, wenn einem gerade nichts einfällt, was man schreiben soll. Kann man sich wunderbar mit beschäftigen. Was bekommt man noch? Man bekommt einen Bibliografieapparat. Das heißt, man bekommt die Möglichkeit, auf andere Veröffentlichungen zu referenzieren. Man hat die Möglichkeit, diese andere Veröffentlichung dann auch aus einer Datenbank herauszuziehen. Das ist insbesondere das benutzte Präsentations- oder Auf-Format. Das ist etwas, was in der Naturwissenschaften mittlerweile überall im Internet abziehbar ist. Das heißt, wenn ich in der Naturwissenschaften bin, in der Physik, und habe da meinen Physik-großen Server, die mir sagen, es gibt eine Publikation, oder auch bei der Informatik, die große SEM, dann sage ich, ich hätte gerne einen Zitat dafür. Dann drücke ich auf den Knopf, und dann bekomme ich das schon genau in dem Format, dass wir TeX brauchen. Um dann hinterher im TeX nur noch zu sagen, ich beziehe mich hiermit auf dieses Buch, oder auf diesen Artikel, und anschließend habe ich eine Literaturliste am Ende meines Buches stehen, die das so wie es sein muss, mit richtiger Formatierung, mit Autor, richtig abgekürzt, oder auch nicht abgekürzt, je nachdem, wie die Journal es haben möchte, dann da. Das heißt, das komplette Thema Bibliografie, Verwaltung, ist im Übrigen etwas, was auch viele Geisteswissenschaftler und Naturwissenschaftler, die mit Formeln gar nicht so viel am Hut haben, zu uns bringt.
Gibt es da nicht auch so ein...
Das heißt BibTeX. Das ist das Format. Dann haben wir auch Formeln natürlich. Was wir auf der Box haben, ist Formeln. Die Möglichkeit eben Formeln zu machen und eben nicht nur die Formel A E gleich M mal C Quadrat, sondern eben Summen, Integrale, mehrzahlige Formeln.
Aber das ist ja jetzt schon ein Feature von TeX, oder ist das...
Das ist TeX-Basis. Nur da stellen wir zum Beispiel in sowas wie LaTeX dann eben die Möglichkeit, diese Formeln wirklich auf einer abstrakten Ebene. So wie gesagt, jetzt hab ich einen Bruch. Das ist der Zähler des Bruchs. Das nenne ich das Bruch. Und Bruch im Bruch.
Während bei TeX sage ich, hier ist eine Zahl über einer Linie und darunter ist auch eine Zahl.
Ja, da habe ich so etwas ähnliches. Hier habe ich eine Zahl. Eine Zahl trenne ich mit Linie oder nicht mit Linie. Diese Anpassung, dass diese Indizes und so die richtige Größe haben, das ist sogar die TeX-Maschine selber, macht das. Das ist etwas, wo man als Autor dann eben hier seine Formeln auch mit einem Tabellensatz natürlich, ja. Das heißt, dass ich meine Tabellen haben möchte. Und auch nicht nur die Tabellen, wo überall... Ich kann solche grauenhaften Tabellen machen, in denen überall die Linien links und rechts und kreuz und quer sind, aber ich kann auch ordentliche Buchsatztabellen machen, so wie sie aussehen sollen. Man muss vielleicht unser Hörer mal sagen, senkrechte Linien kommen in einer gesetzten Tabelle eigentlich nicht vor. Das ist eine Erfindung von Excel. Und wenn man das mal gesehen hat, wenn man mal darauf geachtet hat, wie Tabellen aussehen, die in echten, von Probes gesetzten Büchern vorkommen, das sieht man so gut wie niemals, außer es ist irgendwo eine Sammlung, eine Kataloge oder so etwas, senkrechte Linien. Man hat horizontale Linien, die horizontalen Linien, die Gruppen bilden.
Ich glaube, meine Logarithmentafeln, die hatten sowas.
Logarithmentafeln, deswegen sage ich, das sind so Kataloge oder Sammlungen. Bei so etwas, ja. Aber wenn ich eine Tabelle in einem normalen Dokument habe, und dann kann ich zwar oder sollte ich mir überlegen, ob ich nicht auf die vertikalen Linien dabei verzichte. Das hat nichts mit der Technik zu tun, das hat was mit Typografie zu tun.
Tabellen sind da auch wirklich, meiner Erfahrung nach, häufig eine echte Schwäche von Word-Processing-Programmen. Also, die können es zwar alle irgendwie schon, aber es ist auch gerade im Hinblick auf die Semantik dann immer sehr schwer.
Also, Tabellen sind inherent schwierig. Tabellen ist, meine Setzer-Freunde, also die, die das Satz gelernt haben, sagen auch, Tabellen ist das Schwierigste im Satz, was es gibt. Muss man ganz klar sehen. Tabellen sind deswegen so schwierig, weil sie, weil man da das Thema, diese herrige Lehre, dessen wir bestimmen nur, wie die Semantik ist. Also wir sagen nur, es sollen so und so aussehen und das Programm macht das schon, da bricht das zusammen. Das geht nicht. Eine Tabelle hat inherent etwas, was mit Layout zu tun hat. Weil eine Tabelle inherent etwas ist, wo ich mir überlegen muss, wie ordne ich etwas an? In welchem Abstand? Es sind zwei Dinge in einer Tabelle voneinander. Also nicht im Sinne von wie viel Weisheit Platz dazwischen, sondern wie weit kann der Leser den Bezug zwischen Dingen herstellen? Welche Spalte folgt auf welche Spalte? Das sind solche Punkte, die muss ich als Autor mir auch erstmal überlegen, wie präsentiere ich meine Dinge? Es gibt ganze Bücher darüber, wie macht man am besten Tabellen in der Kommunikation zum Leser hin. Das hat erstmal nichts mit Technik zu tun. Hier geht es erstmal um die Kommunikation zum Leser zu überlegen. Und wenn ich dann mir überlegt habe, was habe ich? Ich habe meinetwegen eine Spalte, die soll so breit sein, dass in ihr nicht umgebrochen wird. Weil ich möchte nicht, dass der Leser durch den Umbruch in der Spalte beeinträchtigt wird. Und dann möchte ich meinetwegen den Rest der Zeile möglichst gleich verteilt auf meine anderen Spalten verteilen. Das sind Dinge, das kann TeX hinterher.
Und da kommt wieder auch viel Gummibänder?
Ja, natürlich, ja klar. Und dann gehe ich her, da gibt es so etwas, wo man so eine Art von... Das ist etwas, wo schon auch... Da muss man ein bisschen die Dokumentation lesen. Das ist etwas, was nicht out of the box sofort geht. Ich habe dann etwas, wo ich hinschreibe, ich beginne eine Tabelle...
Obwohl ich jetzt schon so eine einfache Tabelle kann ich da...
Natürlich, ich sage einfach eine Tabelle, genau, ohne Nachdenken. Ich sage, beginne eine Tabelle, und dann sage ich, ich habe hier meinetwegen zwei Spalten, die sind linksbündig, eine Spalle zentriert, eine Spalle rechtsbündig. Und dann tippe ich die einfach hin und dann sage ich irgendwann, hier ist meine Tabelle zu Ende. Und damit ist meine Tabelle linksbündig, rechtsbündig da. Solche Punkte, wenn ich dann aber anfangen möchte, in die Feinheiten zu gehen, zu sagen, hier habe ich eine, die ist... Zellen zusammenfassen. Auch das ist noch trivial. Zellen zusammenfassen, einfach jetzt fasse ich die nächsten drei Zellen zusammen. Und das, was ich jetzt da neu einsetze, statt nächsten drei Zellen, das soll bitte zentriert sein. Und dann fragt man das genauso hin. Man sagt Multi-Column, das ist, das sagt man, die nächsten drei Zellen und dann bitte zentriert, das was eingesetzt wird und dann kommt das, was einzusetzen ist. Das ist etwas, was dann zwar eingetippt werden muss, natürlich, aber sobald ich irgendwo weiß, ich möchte jetzt die nächsten drei zusammenfassen, dann kann ich das so, wenn ich es markieren würde und sagen würde zusammenfassen. Und in der Oberfläche Velux geht das natürlich auch mit markieren und zusammenfassen anklicken. Wohingegen, wenn ich so dieses, ich tippe das per Hand ein, dann muss ich wieder so einen Backslash-Befehl da eingeben. Das heißt Backslash-Multi-Column.
Ja, also mir ist vor einiger Zeit TeX nochmal auf eine besondere Art und Weise, und da ging es auch gerade um Tabellen nochmal entgegengekommen, weil wir für unsere Veranstaltung zwar eine Software haben, die die ganze Planung macht, das Pentabuff für unseren Kongress, aber es irgendwie immer noch kein Modul gibt, was halt mal eben den Plan dann auch in einer druckbaren Form erzeugt. Und dieser Mangel war und ist auch immer noch ganz groß. Die Notlösung war, dass halt jemand mit TeX eingesprungen ist, sozusagen ein Skript gemacht hat, was eben aus dem Datenbestand, der in XML vorlag, eben Tabellen in TeX formuliert hat, womit man dann das Renderingproblem und Umbrüche und Ausgleich und so weiter einfach wunderbar gelöst hat. Und es gibt halt gar nicht sehr viele Systeme, in denen man mal eben problemlos, also wenn ich jetzt das Problem habe, ich habe so Datenmaterial, ich will ein kleines Skript schreiben, um da eine Tabelle daraus zu machen. Was gibt es denn bitte schon? Es gibt halt HTML. Aber die Fähigkeiten, Tabellen auszuwenden, HTML, das ist unterirdisch. So und ja. Also an diesen ganzen Tabellen, Beispiel, das muss man ja nicht weiter vertiefen. Da habe ich immer so den Eindruck gehabt, dass TeX eigentlich so eine dicke Maschine ist, mit der man eigentlich auch sehr viel mehr als nur Bücher machen kann.
Natürlich.
Was gibt es denn auch so für Anwendungswürdigkeiten, die du dir vorstellen kannst?
Da TeX etwas ist, was letztendlich diese Strukturinformation oder dieses Satzbefehl aus einer Datei herausliegt, kann man diese Dateien generieren. Das heißt, man kann TeX dazu einsetzen, einen vollautomatisierten Satz zu machen. Zum Beispiel, man möchte einen Lampen-Katalog oder so etwas aus einer Datenbank heraus machen. Eine Datenbank irgendwo, wo alle Teile drin sind. Das macht so eine Firma, die ich kenne und möchte da...
Database Publishing.
Database Publishing, genau. Der steht ja auch. Das heißt, irgendwo in der Datenbank stehen Dinge drin und da möchte man einen Katalog machen, der hochgradativ sein soll, weil das sind irgendwie Produkte, die etwas mehr hergeben. Oder auch ein Projekt, in dem eine eigene Firma teilgenommen hat. Wir haben für eine Bank, hier in Frankfurt, die Kontoauszüge. Wir machen das eine Online-Bank, die 1822 direkt. Und für die haben wir ein System gemacht, mit dem wir Kommunikation zu Kunden, die dann zum größten Teil ja online laufen, die bekommen so PDF-Dateien, irgendwo wie online, das ist nun bei der Telekom eingestellt. Und die benutzen TeX auch zur Formatierung. Und das auch schon nicht nur durch uns, sondern auch vorher schon. Das heißt, die haben vorher schon von Anfang an, das waren Leute, die das heute installiert haben, die von der Uni kamen, die TeX da kannten, und die haben die ganze Zeit schon, TeX ist benutzt. Und da werden da pro Monat irgendwie 300.000 plus, 350.000 Auszüge plus irgendwie nochmal 100.000 Kreditkarten-Abrechnungen erzeugt, um das eine Zahl zu nennen. So die Erzeugung von so 350.000 Auszügen dauert ungefähr eineinhalb Stunden zu formatieren. Das sind Schwindigkeiten auch dahinter, das ist eine Leistungsfähigkeit dahinter, die proprietäre Systeme lange nicht erreichen.
Kannst du nochmal die Zahl sagen?
350.000 Auszüge pro Auszug über den Darm gepeilt, typischerweise so sechs Seiten oder so, in eineinhalb Stunden. Das heißt, hast du das mal auf pro Auszug runtergerechnet, oder ist das etwas, was du sagen musst? Wir haben, glaube ich, 0,4 Sekunden oder so Protokoment. Das ist etwas, wir waren auch in einem anderen Projekt übrigens mal tätig von der Firma, was mit Technik zu tun hatte, wo die Telekom-Rechnungen gemacht werden. Also 40 Millionen Rechnungen an die Telekom-Kunden. Da werden proprietäre Systeme eingesetzt. Und die proprietären Systeme sind an der Stelle auch nicht so leistungsfähig. Oder sie sind zwar genauso schnell, dafür brauchen sie aber etwas mehr Späuche und etwas mehr Kapazität von der Hardware her.
Aber es gibt jetzt so, wo wir vorhin schon bei dieser Embeddability gewesen sind, mit Lua. Das TeX selber lässt sich ja nun in ein bestehendes Software zur Laufzeit nicht so ohne weiteres einbinden, weil es ja Pascal ist.
Ja gut, beziehungsweise weil es da auch zu einer Zeit geschrieben war, wo die Embeddability nicht da ist. Also was wir da bei TeX machen, wenn wir so etwas einbinden wollen, ist, dass es ein Programm gibt, das schreibt so eine Datei oder lässt das TeX als Prozess laufen. Und dann schickt es das dem als Eingabe rüber und das TeX gibt als Ausgabe dann das Formatierte zurück.
Ist da nicht schon mal drüber nachgedacht, vorerst TeX neu zu schreiben?
TeX ist in Java neu geschrieben, vor einiger Zeit. Allerdings ist das eher so eine Fingerübung gewesen. Es gibt ein Projekt, das nennt sich AX-TeX. Da werden Experimente mitgemacht. Das ist eine Java-Reimplementierung von TeX.
AX-TeX.
AX-TeX, Experimental-TeX sozusagen. Da geht es darum, dass man da auch neue Basisideen ausprobieren möchte. Sodass man da neue Formen der Absatzformatierung oder neue Formen der Seitenformatierung probieren möchte. Also wo man wirklich in die allerunterste Ebene von TeX eingreifen möchte. Und das ist da zum Teil besser zu machen. Momentan passiert außerdem gerade ein Re-Writer Pascal nach C-Code. Das ist das Lua-TeX-System. Das hat TeX im Wesentlichen in C.
Warum nicht gleich in Lua schreiben?
Das muss man die Leute fragen. Ich nehme alles zu langsam. Das ist eine Frage, wo Geschwindigkeiten dann eine Rolle spielen irgendwann.
Gut, jetzt sind wir ein bisschen abgeschweifert. Ich habe ja eigentlich ein bisschen dabei waren, nochmal zu verstehen, zu erfassen, welche Komplexität einem jetzt LaTeX selber so bietet.
Was bekommt man noch von LaTeX?
Genau. Jetzt hatten wir erst einmal dieses, klar, es gibt Überschriften, man kann Abschnitte definieren. Ist das dann eigentlich so wie bei HTML, dass ich sage, jetzt habe ich hier so die Überschrift, aber es gibt nicht wirklich den Bereich als solchen? Weiß TeX, welche Absätze alle dann in einem Bereich sind?
Die bis zur nächsten Überschrift.
Bis zur nächsten Überschrift. Aber wenn ich jetzt den Abschnitt 3 habe, und dann kommt irgendwie 3.1 und 3.2...
Man hat dann solche Dinge, die heißen Kapitel, Abschnitte, Unterabschnitte, Unterunterabschnitte, also auf Englisch jeweils, by the way. Das heißt dann Chapter, das heißt Section, Subsection, Subsubsection, dann kommt das Paragraph, dann kommt das Subparagraph. Das sind meine Namen. Und dann mein...
Was ist denn ein Subparagraph?
Das ist die fünfte Ebene.
Ja gut, aber so einen normalen Absatz, also ein Paragraph ist halt so das, was man sich so als Absatz vorstellt.
Ja, ein Paragraph wird... Das darf man da nicht eins zu eins übersetzen. Muss man mal sagen, der Paragraph ist etwas, was in der Default-Anzeige meistens so dargestellt wird, dass man es in Fett hat, aber keine eigene Überschriftzeit ist, sondern so ein fetter Beginn eines Absatzes. Man nennt das im Englischen ein Run-In-Title. So rein läuft. Und der Subparagraph ist dann je nach Style typischerweise noch weniger hervorgehoben. Meins wegen in Kapitälchen gemacht.
Aber der normale Lauftext-Absatz ist dann ein Was?
Normalerweise hat man selten Dinge, die tiefer gehen als die Subsection. Denn irgendwann kann man es auch als Leser nicht mehr lesen.
Was ist jetzt der normale Was? Ich habe meine Überschrift. Hier fängt ein Kapitel an. Dann fange ich mit meinem ersten Absatz an. Das ist dieser Absatz, der alles ein bisschen einleitet und der vielleicht für sich noch mal hervorgehoben ist. Was wäre das dann?
Der wird nicht weiter ausgezeichnet. Und wenn ich den besonders hervoraussagen möchte, dann muss ich so eins dieser Zuhörspakete nehmen. Also per Default ist mein erster Absatz.
Was weiß ich denn, wenn ich mir so einen Spiegelartikel mir vorstelle, dann habe ich halt so die Überschrift. Dann gibt es so diesen ersten Absatz, der im Prinzip die ganze Meldung schon mal zusammenfasst, der so fett ist. Und dann kommen dann irgendwie die ganzen anderen Absätze. Was ist jetzt in LaTeX erstmal so, nicht dabei, weil es ja für Bücher ist?
Genau. Beziehungsweise was dabei ist, ist das, weil da kommt das aus dem wissenschaftlichen Umfeld her. Es gibt den so netten Abstract. Wollt man sagen, wenn man am Anfang, nach der Überschrift, dann sagt, ich habe so was wie einen Abstract. Und der Abstract wird typischerweise aber nicht fett gemacht, sondern der wird typischerweise abgesetzt und noch mal eingerückt. Dann dargestellt. Beziehungsweise auch dargestellte Pakete, die den Abstract dann eben anders darstellen. Man hat eben die Zusammenfassung, den Abstract am Anfang. Dann hat man seine Abschnitte. Und dann, was bekommt man noch? Listen natürlich. Man muss ganz klar sehen, das ist eines der häufigsten Dinge, die man in Büchern benutzt. Unnummerierte Liste, also mit Punktenstrichen, Bullets, dicken Punkten, dünnen Punkten, so weiter da. Und auch da ist es so, dass ich mir jetzt den Punkt nicht unbedingt aussuchen muss. Ich kann ihn mir aussuchen. Ich kann sagen, ich hätte ja gerne einen dicken Punkt. Aber wenn ich das nicht tue, sage ich einfach nur, ich habe hier eine Liste. Und dann sucht LaTeX mir einen aus, der sinnvoll ist. In default wird dann erstmal ein ausgefüllter, dicker Punkt auf der ersten Ebene. Und wenn ich dann eine Liste eine Liste habe, dann gibt es dann erstmal so Striche. Und dann gibt es dann dünne Punkte. Und ich kann natürlich das überschreiben. Ich kann sagen, ich hätte gerne hier von Anfang an was anderes. Aber solange ich das nicht jetzt einstelle, bekomme ich einen sinnvollen default von LaTeX. Das Ziel ist es, dass der Autor sich auf seinen Inhalt konzentrieren können soll. Und nicht unbedingt die Informatierung machen soll. Dann bekommt man natürlich so die diversen Ausgangsmöglichkeiten. Man möchte Text inklusiv, in schräg, in fett, in Kapitälchen.
Beziehungsweise an der Stelle würde ich jetzt wieder sagen, ich will eigentlich eher gar nicht sagen, wie das aussieht, sondern ich will sagen, das hier ist ein Begriff, das hier ist eine Übersetzung von, das hier ist ein Salala-Art von Wort.
Ja, gut, da gibt es eins, was Vorbehalt ist, nämlich die sogenannte Hervorhebung. Das nennt sich die, die es emphasize. Und das wird dann dem Style entsprechend angepasst, je nachdem, in welchem Umfeld ich bin. Wird dann kursiv gemacht oder fett gemacht und das passt sich der Umgebung an.
Ja gut, aber wenn ich jetzt so ein typisches Computer-Manual schreibe, dann habe ich ja immer so etwas wie, das ist jetzt eine Eingabe wie auf der Kommandozeile. So, und dann möchte ich ja auch sagen, dieser Text, der jetzt hier mitten im Absatz drinsteht, ist ein Befehl. Und dann würde ich später irgendwann sagen, Befehle werden bei mir in Kurier oder in was auch immer gesetzt. Aber ich will ja nicht an der Stelle sagen, das ist jetzt Kurier.
Das ist etwas, was man sehr früh selber machen kann. Wo ich sagen kann, okay, ich füge so ein neues Makro selber ein. Auf Techebene. In meinem Dokument, wo ich hinschreiben kann, okay, ich habe hier einen Begriff. Oder für solche Dinge, wie zum Beispiel Computer-Code oder Computerprogrammesetzen. Da, wie gesagt, in den letzten 27 Jahren gab es noch mehr Leute, die das machen mussten. Auch dafür gibt es dann wieder das Paket, das heißt hier in dem Fall Listings, wo solche typischen Aufgaben schon mit fertigen Makros vordefiniert sind. Wenn es die aber nicht gäbe, dann würde man als Autor in der Lage sein, sagen zu können, wenn ich möchte, alle meine Begrifflichkeiten, die ich hier habe, speziell in meinem Text erstmal markieren und mich später zu entscheiden, ob die nun kursiv oder fett sein sollen, dann füge ich so ein neuer Makro ein. Das ist etwas, was irgendwie ungefähr 10 Zeichen lang ist, das einführen. Und dann benutze ich das einfach. Und später ändere ich diese Definition und schreibe dann dahin, okay, die soll jetzt fett sein. Und ab dann, in meinem kompletten Dokument, werden alle Begriffe, die so markiert sind, dann als fett gesetzt. Dann, ähm, was man natürlich auch noch hat, sind das Thema Abbildungen.
Genau, Bilder, das wollte ich auch schon fragen.
Abbildungen muss man unterscheiden erst mal zwischen den Bildern selber. Also TeX hat keine oder kaum Möglichkeiten, Bilder zu malen. TeX ist kein Malprogramm. Und das unterscheidet es ganz erheblich von Systemen wie OpenOffice oder Microsoft Word, wo ein integriertes Malprogramm dabei ist. Sondern das Konzept hier ist, dass ich das extern male, mit einem anderen Programm, das spezifisch dafür vorgesehen ist. Und dass ich dieses andere Programm dann ab, seine Datei ablegt, zum Beispiel im PDF-Format oder eben im Postscript-Format. Fast alle Malprogramme können es in diesem Format ablegen. Und man nimmt dann dieses Bild und fügt es als Abbildung in seinen Text ein. Das heißt, man arbeitet mit zwei Programmen. Man arbeitet mit einem Programm, was explizit zum Malen da ist. Und man arbeitet mit einem Programm, das TeX selber nimmt das Ergebnis dieses Malprogramms und setzt es ein. Und was TeX dann liefert, ist die Positionierung, je nach der Seite. Das heißt, das ist eine Abbildung, die dann eine Unter- oder Überschrift hat. Also das kann man sich aussuchen, ob man die Überschrift unten drunter oder unten mit, die dann nummeriert wird, die auch in einem Abbildungsverzeichnis auftauchen kann. Das ist dann auch alles schon dabei. Da muss man nichts mehr tun, da muss man nicht mehr irgendwie belegen, wie man abbildungsverzeichnisse oder mal Tabellenverzeichnisse, weil ich habe auch Tabellen, die ebenfalls so verschoben werden können. Und die sind beweglich, diese Dinge. Das kennen unsere Zuhörer vielleicht von Microsoft Office oder Open Office auch, dass sie, wenn man so eine Grafik einfügt, diese Grafik dann nicht etwas ist, was sich mit dem Text unbedingt verschiebt, sondern dass die zum Beispiel auf einer Seite immer oben sein soll, weil sie den Lesefluss, sie ist so groß, dass sie in den Lesefluss zu sprechen würde. Das heißt, das ist eines der elementaren...
Aber die schon einen Bezug zum Text haben muss.
Genau, das heißt, man hat dann typischerweise im Text stehen, siehe Abbildungen so und so oder siehe Tabelle so und so. Und dann gibt es dann auf der Folge-Seite oder auf der gleichen Seite oben dann die entsprechende Abbildung, die Grafik mit der Unterschrift, wo die Nummer vorkommt. Oder dann möchte man auch so etwas haben können, in dem Verweis, den man in seinem Lauftext stehen hat, möchte man sagen, können siehe Abbildungen 15 auf der folgenden Seite oder auf der vorigen Seite oder auf Seite 25. Man möchte automatisch ausgesucht... Oder oben, genau. Man möchte automatisch ausgesucht bekommen, dass je nachdem, wo die platziert wird, sich der Text ändert. Dass er also ändert von einem Sprachtext wie auf der folgenden Seite, dann überschwenkt in einen Sprachtext wie auf Seite 25, sobald die Platzierung weit nach hinten geht.
Geht das auch so was wie... Was ja auch so ein... Also was ich häufig, wo ich auch, sagen wir mal, bei den anderen Wörterprozessoren häufig immer so an Grenzen stoße, ist, dass ich einfach ein illustratives Bild haben will. Was weiß ich? Man schreibt jetzt über bestimmte Personen. Und man möchte dann schon gerne, dass auf der Seite, wo die Person das erste Mal eingeführt wird, dass dann eben auch das Foto ist. Ohne da aber jetzt explizit drauf zu verweisen, aber ich möchte schon sagen, schon, sondern haben, dass es da ist und dass es dann aber nochmal in seiner eigenen Box steht, mit einem eigenen Text drunter, trotzdem aber sozusagen an einem bestimmten Punkt festgepinnt ist.
Das wäre dann auch forschtebar. Genau. Das ist eine forschtebare... Das ist Autorebox da. Also das ist da, wo man sagt, okay, das ist ein Abbild.
Da tun sich wirklich viele Programme sehr schwer.
Genau. Und das ist das, was ich sagte. Also jedes Mal, wenn ich mal entwegen bei Kunden dann mit Microsoft Office arbeite und da irgendwas im Einfügen bin und ich füge nochmal fünf Absätze ein und meine Grafik verschiebt sich wieder. Und dann wünsche ich mir mein TeX wieder her. Weil das TeX ist einfach in dem Augenblick mir das macht. Und auch wenn ich viele Abbildungen habe, es vernünftig macht und da wirklich in der Lage ist, eine stabile Ausgabe hier zu machen. Und das ist wirklich einer der Highlights, die man da, was das Formatierungsmöglichkeiten von TeX betrifft. Man kann eben sagen, ich habe meine Abbildungen, die sollen nach oben, die sollen nach unten, die sollen in der Mitte bleiben, die sollen nach Möglichkeit hier einsetzt werden, außer wenn kein Platz mehr da ist.
Wenn ich jetzt sowas wie so eine Bildertafel habe, man kennt das ja aus Büchern, wo, was weiß ich, man setzt halt eigentlich alles in schwarz-weiß, aber man will halt ein paar hochwertige Farbdrucker haben und dann möchte man sich so eine Bilderseite zusammenbauen. Da will man ja dann auch klar definieren, an welcher Seite die sind.
Ja gut, das muss man im Text dann schon irgendwann hinschreiben, auch wo sie hinkommen sollen.
Ja klar, ich will dann auch mehrere Bilder nebeneinander anordnen, dass sie sozusagen so eine feste Geschichte haben. Ist das noch zumutbar, das dann auch in TeX zu machen? Man will ja eigentlich alles beisammen machen.
Das ist zumutbar, in TeX zu machen, jawohl. Weil das sind dann so eine Unterbilder. Also man hat Abbildungen, weil was man in Dämmen hat...
Weil dann würde ich dann wieder eigentlich mit Plain-TeX arbeiten.
Nein, Hymnzwillen, da tut man keine Gummibälle aus. Das sind Funktionen, die durch diese Pakete bereitgestellt werden. Da gibt es eben ein Paket, mit dessen hilft man Unter-Abbildungen, also mehrere Abbildungen in Abbildungen. Normalerweise in der Basissystem ist es so, dass man eine Abbildung hat. Und in der Abbildung gibt es dann nur eine Grafik mit einer Unterschrift. Wenn man eine Abbildung haben müsste, muss man mal eine Grafik unten groß und noch mal zwei oben drüber, aber alle mit eigenen Unterschriften, alle mit eigenen Zählern, alle mit eigenen Verweisen auch. Und dafür muss man dann ein Zusatzpaket benutzen, das eben dieses Feature bereitstellt. Und wenn man nicht weiß, wie dieses Zusatzpaket heißt, dann braucht man Hilfe.
Da bräuchte man jemanden, der sich auskennt.
Genau, und dafür gibt es die Benutzergruppen.
Da können wir eigentlich auch mal drüber reden. Ich denke, wir haben jetzt auch, sagen wir mal, den wesentlichen Funktionsumfang, der sich jetzt von LaTeX abzeichnet, ganz gut umrissen. Du bist ja auch in der Community aktiv, sehr sogar. Du hast den Dante-Verein mit gegründet.
Dante ist die deutsche Anwendervereinigung für TeX, eingetragener Verein, gemeinnützig. Das heißt, wenn man da irgendwie mitgeht wird, kann man den Beitrag von der Steuer absetzen. Ich lade alle ein, Mitglied zu werden. Da wir gemeinnützig sind. Wir sind ein Verein. Gut, wir haben uns dann irgendwann mal, um eben genau diese Möglichkeiten der Absetzbarkeit zu machen, uns wirklich als Verein konstituiert. Vorher haben wir uns einfach nur getroffen. Es gab so die deutschen Tech-Interessenten, das war eine Gruppe von Anwendern, die sich einmal im Jahr getroffen haben. Oder auch zweimal im Jahr. Und dann wurde, jetzt muss ich zurückrechnen, wann das war, mittlerweile vor ca. 20 Jahren, haben wir die Anwendervereinigung gegründet. Ich bin Gründungsmitglied von Dante. Auch seit der Zeit natürlich aktiv ununterbrochen. Meine Partnerin ist ebenfalls Gründungsmitglied gewesen. Einen guten Teil unserer persönlichen Freunde habe ich im Tech-Umfeld kennengelernt, muss ich sagen. Es ist schon so, dass das eine Community ist, die auch dann nicht nur hergeht und sagt, man macht nur mit der Arbeit was oder so. Es gibt in fast allen größeren Städten Deutschlands monatliche Treffen von Tech-Anwendern, wo man sich zusammensetzt, so den klassen Stammtisch oder so macht, wo man zusammenklönt, wo man sich erzählt, was hat man gemacht, was hat man privat auch gemacht und wo dadurch ein privater Zusammenhalt, wo man gemeinsam Sommerfeste feiert. Das heißt, die Community ist nicht nur etwas, wo es darum geht, zu sagen, ich mache hier einen ein bisschen einen technischen Austausch oder so etwas. Die Community geht darüber hinaus und bietet auch ihren Mitgliedern über den technischen Austausch eine Privatverbindung mit an.
Das liegt......gegische Funktionen.
Ja, genau, so ist das. Leute treffen es schon mal gerne und quatschen gerne zusammen und gehen auch gerne gemeinsam in den Treib.
Aber es ist auch ein guter Ort, um, sagen wir mal, eine dritte Problem zu lösen. Ich denke mir, wenn ich mich jetzt soweit in LaTeX eingelesen habe und jetzt vor einer Diplomarbeit stehe, die einen gewissen Umfang hat, aber die, sagen wir mal, auch jetzt rein vom Publishing her eine Herausforderung ist, und dann stehe ich irgendwie vier Wochen vorher da und frage mich, wie kriege ich denn jetzt meine Bildertafel zusammen oder ich würde jetzt hier ganz gerne mal so einen permutierten Index in meine Seiten reinschreiben. Ist was eigentlich auch dabei? Dieser Großartige, der ist irgendwie verschwunden. Also als ich angefangen habe, meine ersten Computerbücher zu kaufen, da war so der permutierte Index, das war dann immer der totale Renner und ich kenne einfach nichts Praktischeres. Das finde ich heute fast überhaupt nicht mehr. Ist das Bestandteil von LaTeX?
Index, ja, weil permutierter Index wüsste ich momentan...
Was ist meine Frage?
Nein, permutierter Index ist nicht anscheinend von LaTeX. Also was wir mit LaTeX machen, ist natürlich Index. Also glaubst du halt, ist das momentan meine persönliche Spielwiese sogar in der LaTeX-Entwicklung. Internationales, die Erzeugung internationaler multilingualer Indizes. Also Indizes im Sinne von das, was hinten als Stichwort verzeichnet ist, am Buch hinten dran steht. Wenn ich habe ein Software-System, habe ich mitgeschrieben, das heißt Xindi, das als Teilprogramm in diesem LaTeX mitbenutzt wird und das zurzeit für 50 Sprachen unterstützt. Um diverse Sortierverfahren in den, bis hin zum klingonischen Sortieren hat den jemand benutzt. So Freaks gibt es immer. Genau, Freaks gibt es immer, das ist ganz klar. Ich habe das System geschrieben, in dem kann man definieren, welche Zeichen gibt es in einer Sprache, wie werden die sortiert, wie macht man Wörter daraus. Das ist mein persönliches Spiel, wie sie sich momentan ansehen. Aber wenn man, derjenige, der vor dem Problem steht, wo wendet er sich hin, er wendet sich insbesondere an eine Newsgroup, das heißt über das Web, Zugreifbar, über Groups, Google, die de.com.txt.tech heißt. Also de.com.txt für Computer, Text, für Textverarbeitung und tech heißt. Und da hängen die Leute rum und beantworten Fragen. Das ist etwas, wo man sich hinwendet, wo man Fragen hat. Da gibt es eine sogenannte FAQ, die auch die wirklich die meisten Fragen oder viele Fragen schon mal beantwortet. Diese FAQ ist auch auf einer von unseren Web-Servern einfach abrufbar, zum Beispiel von www.dante.de. Das ist da, wo man die abrufen kann. Und dort kann man einfach seine Frage stellen. Und es wird dann geholfen, wenn man so schön sagt. Und da werden sie geholfen.
Da werden sie geholfen. Ja, vielleicht mal so zum Endspurt nochmal das Thema Werkzeuge. Weil nun ist natürlich auch, wir haben ja schon gesehen, einerseits ist es in gewissem Maße zumutbar, zumindest überschaubarer Dokumente, jetzt auch mal so from scratch in der LaTeX-Sprache selber zu schreiben. Auch wenn es vielleicht erstmal ungewohnt ist. Hat aber eben diverse Vorteile, unter anderem auch den Vorteil, dass man eben sowas auch sehr schnell mit einer Software oder einem sonstigen Skript generieren kann. Stichwort Database Publishing oder eben auch andere Fälle, wo man eben einfach mal irgendein brauchbares Dokument, ein Handout und so weiter, generieren will aus etwas, was man ohnehin schon irgendwo in seinem Computer in der einen oder anderen Form stehen hat. Aber manchmal ist es ja auch einfach ganz sinnvoll, dann eben überzugehen in ein gestütztes System, wo man dann auch im Idealfall mit so einer GUI arbeiten kann. Jetzt hast du schon das Lüx erwähnt.
Das Lüx ist das, was dem Office am nächsten kommt. Das ist dafür aber auch in gewisser Weise eingeschränkt. Lüx bietet eine Oberfläche an, die vollkommen der grafischen Oberfläche von normalen Office-Systemen darunter. Normale Office-Systeme verstehe ich etwas wie Microsoft Office und Open Office. Nicht so etwas wie Framemaker. Framemaker geht darüber hinaus. Das sind professionelle Systeme, die dem TeX viel näher stehen, als das bei den Office-Systemen da ist. Und Lüx stellt dadurch aber auch nur eine gewisse Auswahl erstmal zur Verfügung. Das heißt, ein Teil der Fragen, die du mir gestellt hast, wie das Thema zum Beispiel Bildertafeln machen oder so, das ist mit Lüx nicht mehr so einfach möglich. Weil Lüx eben eine relativ statische Oberfläche bereitstellt von Dingen, die man dann tun kann und die man damit machen kann. Und wenn ich eben diese Features, die ich vorhin genannt habe, wie automatische Numerierung meiner Unterabschnitte mithaben möchte, dann fängt das an mir in diesem Lüx nicht mehr ganz so einfach zu sein. Das heißt, sehr komplexe Dokumente komme ich irgendwann an meine Grenzen.
Aber wenn ich jetzt von jemand anders ein LaTeX-Dokument erhalte, dann kann ich das in Lüx laden und editieren und wieder speichern.
Genau, dafür ist das auch sehr gut geeignet.
Das ist dann aber immer davon abhängig, wie viele von diesen Erweiterungspaketen sozusagen genutzt werden.
Genau.
Kann ich die dann auch automatisch in Lüx mit nutzen oder ist Lüx da an der Stelle beschränkt, wie viele dieser Pakete?
Die meisten von den, nein, es ist beschränkt, aber die Beschränkung kommt erst sehr spät zum Tragen. Die meisten dieser Pakete kann Lüx laden. Es gibt nur Pakete, die redefinieren die Eingabe massiv. Es gibt ein Paket, dass man XML direkt lesen kann. Und XML wirklich setzen kann. Also dass man so einen XML-Text mit spitzen Klammern, diese HTML-Dinge, nehmen kann.
Also, dass man sozusagen TeX-Semantik hat, aber XML-Syntax?
Syntax, genau. Und da steigt Lüx aus. Also das ist etwas, Lüx ist für LaTeX da. Also Lüx ist nicht dafür da, das TeX genärlich zu machen. Es ist für LaTeX als Eingabesystem da. Dann gibt es, die meisten unserer Zuhörer werden hier auf Windows arbeiten.
Das würde ich jetzt aber nicht so laut sagen.
Das ist einfach dennoch klar.
Da wäre ich mir nicht so sicher. Also sicher wäre ich mir da auf keinen Fall.
Gut, dann wollen wir mit Linux weiterfahren.
Ich würde sagen, die Zuhörer verwenden wahrscheinlich ziemlich alles.
Gut, dann hast du mich aus dem Konzept gebracht jetzt.
Du darfst trotzdem die Werkzeuge für Windows erwähnen, ich erlaube dir das.
Gut, ich muss dazu sagen, ich bin ja auch kein Windows-Benutzer. Ich selber gehöre zur Linux-Fraktion. Das ist mein persönlicher Arbeitsumfeld. Im Windows gibt es ein Tool, das nennt sich Technik-Center.
Also TeX wieder mit C.
Ja, genau. Und das ist etwas, wo man zwar noch diese Auszeichnungen...
Technik mit K oder mit C?
Mit C. Wo man die Auszeichnungen zwar noch sieht, also wo man noch sieht, dass es so wechselnde Dinge gibt, aber wo man eben die üblichen Knöpfe und Symbole hat, wie man sie vom Office her kennt, um sich eben seine Listen, seine Tabellen und sonstige Dinge einzugeben. Und wo man dann eben so eine Preview, das heißt, man hat das irgendwo eingetippt und möchte wissen, wie sieht es denn nun mal aus hinterher, auf Knopfdruck dann direkt angezeigt bekommt. Bei Lüx sieht man schon direkt mehr oder weniger... Bei der Eingabe, das ist wie sie weg. Und da ist es nur so ein Preview-Modus. Das heißt, Technik-Sende dient dazu, mithilfe einer grafischen Oberfläche mir zu helfen, meinen Text effektiver einzugeben. Ist aber kein Visivic-Tool. Und das ist der Schwerpunkt der TeX-Tools. Und der TeX-Eingabewerkzeuge ist von dieser Art. Das heißt, bis auf Lüx gibt es... Es sind alle anderen, basierend darauf, dass man zwar seine TeX-Sachen noch sieht, aber dass man möglichst nahe ein Preview dabei hat. Dass man bei der Eingabe nach Möglichkeit zum Teil schon sieht, wie wir das aussehen hinterher.
Dass man auch nicht wegkommt vom Source.
Dass man aber der Source nach wie vor da hat.
Das sind eigentlich auch die idealen Werkzeuge, um eigentlich TeX zu erlernen, weil man ist schon gestützt, aber man sieht trotzdem noch...
Genau, man hat dann also irgendwo so etwas, wo man... Und auch selbst bei Formuleingabe, wo man dann zum Teil dann sagt, okay, ich beginne hier meine Formel und dann füge ich meine Summe ein und dann füge ich mein zugehöriges Zähler und Nenner ein oder mein Exponent ein oder ich habe eben meine Liste, meine Tabelle und diese Konstrukte, die muss ich nicht wissen, wie sie heißen, sondern ich wähle sie aus dem Menü aus. In der Linux-Welt ist ein ähnliches Tool Kail, K-Y-L-E, geschrieben, das auch sehr da ist und natürlich das vorhin schon genannte Auktech. Das ist also den Emacs zu benutzen, der wirklich sehr weitgehend das Ganze unterstützt. Unter dem Mac gibt es auch so etwas, dessen Name ich allerdings momentan nicht weiß, da ich selber keinen Mac habe und ihn nicht.
Ich vermute, du sprichst von Tech-Shop?
Ja, es gibt so eine integrierte Oberfläche. Ist da jemand namens Kinch dabei genannt? Richard Kinch?
Richard Koch.
Koch heißt der mit Nachnamen. Dann ist das das, was ich meine. Ich weiß, das ist einer der Entwickler, die an diesem System arbeiten. Das heißt, in der Mac-Welt würde es dann Tech-Shop heißen.
Wobei es sich auch um GPL-Software handelt?
Alles, worüber ich gerade gesprochen habe, ist Open-Source-Software. Es gibt auch noch ein proprietäres System für Windows, das heißt WinEDT, das kommt aus Australien, das auch eine Oberfläche bereitstellt, um TeX möglichst effizient, LaTeX möglichst effizient eingeben zu können. Diese Eingabesysteme kennen diese Pakete zum guten Teil schon.
Und alle diese Systeme kommen dann sozusagen mit PDF-TeX als Kern? Das heißt, nicht das Ur-TeX, sondern das angepasste, aber immer noch in Pascal geschriebene System, was aus TeX PDF macht.
Es kann nach wie vor noch DVI machen, so ist es nicht, aber auch wenn das niemand mehr benutzt.
Und das LaTeX ist in TeX geschrieben. Das ist sozusagen ein in der Sprache TeX geschriebenes Makrosystem. Das heißt, ich schreibe LaTeX oder ich benutze ein Tool, mit dem ich LaTeX erstellen lasse oder mich dabei unterstützen lasse, das zu tun. Dann geht das in den LaTeX-Prozessor, der macht TeX draus, dann geht das in das PDF-TeX, der macht PDF draus und dann habe ich sozusagen eigentlich schon mein Ergebnis.
Genau, das ist etwas, was ich mir dann mit so einem Akrobat-Räder anschaue oder mit XPTFK-PTF, wie auch immer mein PDF-Preview oder drücken lassen.
Kann ich denn auch Alperlinks machen?
Jawohl, das ist etwas, was sogar...
Das ist ja sozusagen auch in PDF nutzbar.
Genau und das sogar vollautomatisch. Das heißt, wenn man dann ein Index hat, dann sind die Seitenzahlen natürlich links dahin, wo man sie hat. Oder wenn man einen Inner-Zusatz hat, dann sind die Inner-Zusatzen natürlich sofort links auf dahin, wo die entsprechenden Überschriften beginnen. Das ist nichts, was man da noch mühselig nachbauen muss, sondern das ist etwas, was sofort gemacht wird.
Was man sozusagen kostenlos dazubekommt.
Ja, aber auch links auf Extern-URL-Quellen, wo wenn man dann im PDF draufklickt, dann eben der Browser entsprechend hochgeht. Das wurde hier in Deutschland im Übrigen sogar vom Heiko Oberdieck entwickelt.
Das heißt Hyper-Ref, heißt dieses zugehörige Subsystem. Manchmal geht es ja auch weniger darum, jetzt wirklich den Satz zu machen. Also es ist immer gut, wenn man die Optionen hat. Aber manchmal möchte man es auch einfach nur im Web haben. Und dann natürlich idealerweise als HTML. Gibt es denn eine einfache Methode? Und ist das sozusagen ein gelöstes Problem, wie man aus TeX einfach HTML macht?
Ein gelöstes Problem mit nicht schönem Aussehen. Da muss man sehen, dass das nicht... Das ist etwas, wie man etwas tut, was sowohl online gut aussieht, wie auch gedruckt gut aussieht. Und das mit Open Source-Werkzeugen ist meiner Ansicht nach ein ungelöstes Problem zurzeit. Wir haben die ganze TeX-Landschaft, die den gedruckten Bereich wunderbar hinbekommt. Wir haben das Combo-XML-CSS, mit dessen Hilfe man letztendlich schmittelbar die Online-Sachen gut aussehen könnte. Und zwischen den jeweiligen Welten gibt es nur Krücken darüber. Das heißt, man kann... Es gibt etwas, das nenne ich LaTeX-to-HTML. Da wirft man ein LaTeX-Dokument vor, und daraus kommen Webseiten raus. Die erfüllen einfach die Ansprüche an einen professionellen Design der Webseite nicht.
Woran liegt das?
Das liegt daran, weil Schneemann die Mühe gemacht hat, das wirklich vernünftig hinzubeißen. Implementierungsfrage meiner Ansicht nach.
Ich meine, wenn man sich die Formatierungsmöglichkeiten anschaut, die mittlerweile mit CSS3 und vergleichbaren Webstandards und sagen wir mal jetzt auch der simantischen Kraft von HTML5, was sich ja jetzt abzeichnet. Wenn man sich auch überhaupt anschaut, wie Web-Applikationen heutzutage rüberkommen und keinerlei Probleme haben, Dinge zu positionieren und flexibel zu formatieren, sollte es ja nun eigentlich gar nicht so das Problem sein. Es hat sich noch keiner gemacht.
Es hat sich niemand dran gemacht und umgekehrt ist es genauso.
Das heißt, hier gibt es eine Development Opportunity. Da kann man sich sozusagen noch einen Blumenkranz verdienen und Anerkennung reinschaufeln, wenn man vielleicht mal dieses Problem...
Wir haben das Problem ja umgekehrt auch. Wenn ich zum Beispiel etwas habe, was ich im Web machen möchte, wo schon entweder... Ja, ich bin ein HML oder XHML oder FMXXML und dann anschließend mit dem XSL Style Sheet, das ist noch HTML-Umbauer, was dann sogar im Profibereich die eher übliche Variante ist. Und dann möchte ich aus meinem XML-Dokument vielleicht auch nochmal das Ganze gedruckt ausgeben. Und es gibt keine gute Open Source-Lösung dafür. Es gibt proprietäre Systeme, die mit XML-FO arbeiten, die aber auch von der Qualität her nicht unbedingt das Gleiche liefern, was TeX liefert. Und es gibt irgendwo eine Open Source-Implementierung bei Apache von XML-FO, die krebst darum. Fast die beste Implementierung von XML-FO heutzutage ist TeX-basiert. Und auch die ist etwas, was eher, naja...
Die von Apache ist...
Nein, nein, nicht die von Apache. Das ist eine Java-Anwendung. Also XML-FO. Es gibt eine, die nennt sich Passiv-TeX. Die ist in UK, also in England, gemacht worden.
Die machte aus XSL-FO?
Nein, die nimmt XSL-FO und implementiert sozusagen die Formatierung.
Und setzt das in TeX und lässt es dann mit TeX in etwas anderes ersetzen.
Also in PDF dann.
Das heißt Passiv-TeX.
Vielleicht sollten wir noch mal kurz sagen, XSL-FO ist so einer der beiden Kernkomponenten des XSL-Standards, wo auch noch XSLT dazugehört und das ist so das Versprechen, dass man eben auch in XML Seitenbeschreibungen formulieren kann.
FO steht für Formatting Objects und das muss man sagen, es gibt da Proprietäresysteme, die machen das ganz nett und ganz praktisch, aber es gibt in der Open Source-Welt nichts, womit man hochqualitativen Satz aus XML Dokumenten herausbekommen kann. Und gerade wenn man etwas heutzutage in der heutzutage in der Publishing-Welt lebt, wo man sowohl Richtung Web als auch Richtung gedruckt gehen möchte und beides haben möchte, muss man sagen, ist hier wirklich ein Bruch da. In der Open Source-Tool-Landschaft, das noch der weiteren Entwicklung hat, wo wir einfach mehr bräuchten.
Ein anderer Bruch, der mir aufgefallen ist, ist, wie haben wir schon gesagt, man sieht so TeX-Dokumenten schon an, dass sie welche sind. Das liegt natürlich vor allem daran, dass eben auch so die klassischen Fonds, die du ja eigentlich schon erwähnt hast, häufig zur Anwendung kommen. Kann ich denn aktuelle Fonds auch verwenden für TeX?
Jegliche Open-Type-Fonds, die man irgendwo hat, jegliche Type-1-Fonds, die man hat, sind in TeX out of the box benutzbar.
Okay, also da gibt es keinerlei Einschränkungen?
Nein, das ist etwas da. Das war vor 10 Jahren oder 15 Jahren mal der Fall. Und es ist auch so, ich würde behaupten, dass es viel mehr Bücher in TeX gibt, die du einfach nicht erkennst, dass sie TeX sind. Okay, das ist eine Ansage. Weil das einfach, natürlich das original TeX-Lehrer, das original TeX-Fonds fällt auf. Weil diese Art von modernen Fonds, die hat heutzutage.
Und was ist so mit dem Authoring von Unicode-Zeichen angefangen, halt jetzt schon bei RöÖ? Ich meine, das UrteX war natürlich in ASCII definiert. Wie ist das heute? Kann man da auch in UTF-8 schreiben?
Ja, genau. Das ist die übliche, die übliche Umgebung eigentlich, in der man damit...
Okay, also das PTF-TeX ist an der Stelle schmerzfrei und alles einfach.
Ja, gut. Das sind die Entwicklungen, muss man auch dazu sagen, die in den letzten Jahren gelaufen sind. Das ist nicht etwas, das jetzt so schon seit Ewigkeiten so ist. In den letzten Jahren wurde eben zuerst PTF-Support, dann das Thema UTF-8 als Basissache. Diese Entwicklung hieß als Subprojekt CTECH, also XETech geschrieben. Diese CTECH-Leute, die haben dann auch das Thema OpenType angegangen und haben den OpenType-Support eingebaut. Das sind zuerst Entwicklungen gewesen, die nebenan daher gelaufen sind und die dann zu einem späteren Zeitpunkt, das spätere Zeitpunkt ist erst 2007, 2008 gewesen, deswegen sage ich, das ist eine der aktuellen Entwicklungen. Hier können wir sehen, das TeX-Projekt lebt auch noch und macht noch was. Das dann zusammengenommen haben. Momentan gibt es noch diesen Strang, den ich vorhin angeschnitten habe mit Lua-TeX. Auch das fängt jetzt an zusammen zu laufen und um da diese unterschiedlichen Entwicklungsstränge, wo Leute in unterschiedliche Richtungen entwickelt haben, weil ihr Bedarf ein anderer war. Die einen wollten PDF machen, die anderen wollten das Thema OpenType mit mehr Fonds haben. Die nächsten haben Unicode gebraucht, weil sie internationale Autorenschaft hatten, dabei sehr stark hatten. Die dritten haben die Programmierung verbessern wollen und diese Entwicklungen, die so seit 2000 ungefähr gelaufen sind, die werden jetzt in den letzten zwei Jahren vermehrt zusammengefügt und vermehrt wieder zu einem gemeinsamen System unifiziert. Also noch vor vier Jahren hätte man sich das mehr aussuchen müssen, in welche Richtung man geht. Dann konnte das OpenType, dann irgendein System, konnte noch nicht so hundertprozentig mit dem PDF und so weiter. Also das war etwas, was sich jetzt wirklich in den letzten zwei Jahren als schöne Entwicklung kumuliert hat.
Ja, wo trifft sich denn die Szene außerhalb der regelmäßigen Stammtische? Gibt es denn einen jährlichen Kongress oder etwas Vergleichbares auf nationaler oder internationaler Ebene?
Auf allen Ebenen. Wir haben in Deutschland zweimal im Jahr treffen wir uns. Einmal als Kongress und einmal nur mit Tutorien. Das ist wechselnd. Das ist eine sogenannte Frühjahrstagung. Das ist die große Tagung mit Vorträgen auch. Und Tutorien, die im Übrigen kostenlos sind, die Tutorien. Das heißt, da muss man nicht mehr bezahlen. Das ist ein Teil dessen, was man als gemeinnütziger Verein eben für die Öffentlichkeit tut. Immer im März ungefähr. Da muss man auf der Webseite von Dante.
Mit wechselnden Orten?
Mit wechselnden Orten, genau. Nachschauen, wo die jeweils ist. Dieses Jahr waren wir in Wien. Das war sehr schön.
Also auch nicht auf Deutschland beschränkt.
Deutschsprachiger Raum, ja. Und dann gibt es die sogenannte Herbsttreffen, das dann im September oder so stattfindet. Und wo in dem Herbsttreffen dann keine Vorträge mehr. Meistens sind sie ein etwas kleineres Programm, wo dann eine Tagung Tutorien da sind und Leute treffen sich dort. Die Teilnehmer-Mannschaft, wie viele Leute sind das dann, die ungefähr hinkommen? Das sind um die 100 oder so bei der Tagung 150 vielleicht. Und bei der kleinen kommen dann so 60 oder so Leute zusammen. Dann gibt es auf der europäischen Ebene eine Tagung, die Eurotechtagung. Das ist die, findet dieses Jahr in Delft, in Holland statt. Letztes Jahr war sie in Irland, in Cork. Das ist im Juli oder August. Das weiß ich momentan nicht auswendig. Ich weiß nur, ich bin in Urlaub gerade. Das heißt, kann ich nicht hinfahren. Ansonsten wäre ich gerne hingefahren, nämlich Eurotecht. Ja, Eurotecht. Und da treffen sich dann, wie der Name schon sagt, schwerpunktmäßig europäische Benutzer. Da gibt es auch ein anspruchsvolleres Tagungsprogramm noch mal, das dann als Sprache Englisch hat, als Konferenzsprache. Und dann gibt es noch die TeX-Users Group weltweit, die auch jährlich eine Tagung veranstaltet. Und da kommt immer so einmal in USA, einmal in Europa und einmal irgendwo anders auf der Welt. Das ist so eine Art Zyklus, den die so von der Tag aus machen. Tag ist die TeX-Users Group.
Eurotech ist Ende August, Anfang September. Ist denn jetzt die deutschsprachige Gemeinde jetzt auffällig besser organisiert oder weniger? Wo sind sozusagen die Kernaktivitäten zu verzeichnen, international gesehen?
Also Deutschland ist sehr aktiv. Wir haben zum einen die größte Benutzervereinigung weltweit. Wir haben momentan über 2000 Mitglieder. TeX wird auch benutzt nach wie vor. Wir haben auf unserem Server, wo wir die TeX-Software zum Download anbieten, das Problem, dass wir momentan die 3TB Grenze Downloads jeden Monat sprengen. Das heißt, bei uns wird es für die Software-Downloads benutzt. Da sind zum Teil automatische Updates dabei, aber die laden in beiden Updates ja auch kein komplettes System neu runter, sondern nur das, was eben gerade aktualisiert wird oder so. Das heißt, es ist eine sehr, sehr intensive Nutzergemeinde auch da. Und die Benutzergruppen in anderen Ländern sind nicht ganz so groß wie Danda. Und wir haben auch von der Danda dadurch die Möglichkeit, zum Teil Entwicklungen noch mal mehr zu unterstützen. Es gibt zum Beispiel von der Danda einen Entwicklungsfonds, wo Leute, die Reisekostenzuschüsse brauchen, weil sie sich mal treffen wollen, wir das von der FUNF Verein aus gemeinsam machen. Wenn sie so eine Entwicklergruppe, wo halt wie üblich irgendwo sitzen und die sagen, wir wollen mal einen Workshop machen mit allen Leuten, dann bezahlen wir vom Verein die Reisekosten aus, damit die sich mal treffen können. Denn die schreiben ja die Software, die die Vereinsmitglieder machen. Das ist der Grund, wieso Leute auch dem Verein beitreten. Sie könnten das Programm ja einfach so umsonst bekommen. Es ist ja einfach überall runterladbar. Es ist nicht so, dass man da beitritt, um die Software zu bekommen. Man hört bei, weil man gesagt hat, oh, das ist schön, dass Leute sich engagieren und Leute da was tun. Und ich möchte ein Stück weit auch dann einen Beitrag dazu leisten, dass es weitergeht. Und wir versuchen eben von Seiten des Vereins aus, Entwicklungsaktivitäten zu fördern, und aber auch so Schulungsaktivitäten zu fördern. Oder auch eben Werbung zu machen, das ist ein bisschen auf dem Linux-Tag mit dem Stand, dieses in Berlin, der jetzt demnächst irgendwie diese Woche ist.
Also diese Woche ist, heute ist der 21. Juni. Jetzt, wo wir das hier aufnehmen, 2009, müssen wir mal sagen, weil Chaosradio Express wird ja noch in 500 Jahren gehört. Und ja, da seid ihr dann sozusagen auch immer präsent.
Genau. Und da kann man die Leute kennenlernen, mit ihnen quatschen und die sind alle nett. Niemand frest euch auf. Wenn ihr zum Littungstag kommt, schaut einfach mal vorbei, am Dantebooth.
Jetzt habe ich auch den Zwang, hier diese Sendung ganz schnell zu veröffentlichen. Mal gucken, ob ich das mal rechtzeitig schaffe. Ja, Joachim, ich denke, wir haben es, oder?
Jawohl.
Super. Ja, das war ein sehr illustrerter Überblick, wie ich mir immer gewünscht habe, hier für dieses Format. Vielen Dank. Und ja, ich hoffe, es geht weiter. Ich hoffe auch, dass das Webproblem sich bald mal löst, weil das wäre sicherlich auch etwas, wo ich denke, was Techno mal einen ganz neuen Schub geben könnte. Und ich glaube, ich muss mir jetzt auch noch mal an das Thema heransetzen.
Und gut, ich hoffe, für unsere Zuhörer war es interessant, mal zu hören, was man tun kann, wie es auch dahin kam, ein bisschen Kontext zu hören.
Da bin ich mir sicher. Und das werden wir dann auch erfahren, weil ihr werdet ja alle ganz fleißig wieder eure Kommentare ablassen. Und zwar in unserem Blog, blog.chaosradio.cc.de. In Ausnahmefällen auch gerne mal eine Mail an chaosradio.cc.de, wenn ihr eine genauere Nachfrage habt, die jetzt nicht so die Öffentlichkeit ist. Aber ich freue mich vor allem immer über Kommentare im Blog. Und da könnt ihr ja dann mal sagen, was wir jetzt hier alles falsch gemacht haben und wie man es viel besser hätte machen können oder wie es euch auch einfach nur gefallen hat. Ich sage jetzt erst mal Danke, Joachim. Und ja, ich hoffe, es hat euch gefallen und wir hören uns sicherlich bald wieder hier bei Chaosradio Express.